ok das sound moment irgendwas ich habe nämlich gerade update gemacht von meinem
elgato gedöns und das hat irgendwelche komische neuen sound sachen installiert
aber scheint zu funktionieren oder also so es test ja doch doch doch doch das
funktioniert das funktioniert als noch filters gucken passt alles alles gut gut
da war schon bis der stream richtig online ist und basteln wir wieder ein bisschen ich weiß
nicht ob ich mir was gescheites gekauft habe oder nicht müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren
man könnte sich ja sonst nix ein agierer ist da toxic auch am start aber wir haben
mit kamera action warum ruckelt das was
hier los dann aber keine 60 fps von meiner hand neues nass daheim nicht wirklich nur
neues nass ich bin gerade überlegen ob ich meine intel low power intel kiste dadurch ersetze das
war mal schauen mal gucken ich ehrlich gesagt habe ich mir nur gekauft weil es mir danach war
einfach weil ich mir gedacht habe wir brauchen wir brauchen was neues hier guckt also das ist
ein zeigt euch mal wobei man kann das hoch kann kann man das glaube ich gar nicht
richtig stellen guck mal hier das ist ein man das jetzt sieht ein hp microserver gen ten plus ist
aber auch schon zwei jahre alt das teil also als es rausgekommen ist es ist nicht das neueste und
so ultra power wie mein aktueller intel ist es wahrscheinlich nicht aber was ich an der sache ganz nice finde ist dass es einen display kann zumindest
ist das unser Herz oder jaегaring einmal zum aushalten aber ich glaube ich habe das alles vergessen요
halt einfach komplett fertiges teil ist eigentlich falsch investiert warum riecht
danach dass der gut stromhunger hat ich weiß es nicht müssen wir gucken also wir
können uns das angucken ich habe ja hier wie soll ich den den watt champ dran
kann man gleich mal gucken was es braucht aus der firma gesnackt nein
nein habe ich mir bestellt bei amazon leute wisst ihr was ich habe heute meine
dritte 5g antenne bekommen heute morgen beim beim samstag beim doktor ja auch
was mit euch los warum vergibt ihr samstags termine aber ich meine ich habe
mich nicht beschweren fünfte dritte 5g antenne am start der
keyboard wieder bett gemacht ja der bot im discord ist teilweise echt lahm
naja ja richtig massive also wir gucken uns das heute mal zusammen an ich werde
das nicht fertig einrichten also
wir gucken uns das heute mal zusammen an ich werde das nicht fertig einrichten
was wir uns machen wir machen das ding als macht haben ich
mache hier oben erst einmal fullscreen dann kleine also eben wir machen das
machen hier oben erst einmal fullscreen dann kleine also eben wir machen das
mal auf gucken mal rein hier ist und wie sie wie sie weiter drehen kann man das
mal auf gucken mal rein hier ist und wie sie wie sie weiter drehen kann man das noch
noch
noch wobei wenn ich wirklich hier ist tischgrenze
wobei wenn ich wirklich hier ist tischgrenze
wobei wenn ich wirklich hier ist tischgrenze ne passt seitdem ist das wähler
ne passt seitdem ist das wähler
ne passt seitdem ist das wähler ist der wlan empfang schlechter ja ganz
ist der wlan empfang schlechter ja ganz
Bestimmt. Ja, Kyokun,
27 Monate.
Richtig nice hier. Dafür
bräuchte man eigentlich eine neue Keksfarbe, aber
habe ich nicht. Gleich fällt die
Cam um. Die Cam kann nicht umfallen.
Die ist, die Kamera, die ist
zwischen diesem
Elgato Ring Light montiert
und das ist sehr massiv
an einem recht massiven Tisch fest.
Ich meine, der Tisch wackelt.
Und noch nicht mal großartig,
wenn man drauf haut.
Was ist besser? Minis Forum Elite
HM80. Warum ist das besser? Hat es einen PCI-Express
Slot für 10G
und es hat keinen Wechselrahmen
für Platten.
Was soll man damit?
Bringt mir doch überhaupt nichts. Hat keinen
Wechselrahmen für Platten.
Hat keinen PCI-Express Slot. Was soll ich damit?
Useless.
Ist das der HP
mit dem Xeon? Ja.
Die gibt es in zwei Varianten.
Warte mal, wo steht das
denn jetzt?
Ja, sie gibt es in zwei Varianten.
Den gibt es mit einem Xeon
E2224 und einem
Pentium G
Silber
noch was, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe die Variante mit dem Xeon.
Man kann da sogar einen Elo reinpappen
mittlerweile und Remote drauf zugreifen, aber
ich habe es ohne Elo-Kit
gekauft.
Heute mir tut der Arm ein bisschen weh.
Da wächst die neue Antenne gerade.
Heute Morgen
gab es wieder richtig Drama beim Doktor.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit manchen Leuten.
Was mit manchen Leuten los ist.
Ich saß im
Wartezimmer.
Wie ist die Geschichte mit der...
Ach ja,
warte mal, lass mal überlegen. Da war was.
Was war das nochmal?
Chat erinnert mich mal dran.
Achso, ja, genau.
Wir haben gemietet.
Gut, dass du fragst.
Es ist genauso gewesen, wie ich das im Stream
vermutet habe. Das ist nur
vorgeschoben gewesen. Ich soll ihm zeigen,
wie man eine Datei löscht. Es sind ja noch
zwei Leute von diesem Dienstleister
aufgetaucht, der für uns die Software
für diesen Server entwickelt.
Und eigentlich wollten die nur, dass ich
eine File-Liste erzeuge mit Dateien,
die sie später löschen können.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die das immer so verschleiern müssen
alles und nicht einfach sagen können, was Sache ist.
Wir haben jetzt auf der Arbeit übrigens
zweiten Corona-Fall.
Jetzt sind alle zwangs Homeoffice.
Ich bin ja eh schon
Dauer-Homeoffice gerade.
So, also Leute, ich zeige euch
jetzt mal kurz die Hardware, was wir hier
am Start haben, bevor wir
anfangen. Also, ich habe
einmal mir diesen Mikro-Server
gekauft.
Wisst ihr, was gut ist?
Ich bin jetzt gezwungen, die Maus raus zu
bewegen, dass hier oben das X weggeht. Das ist
gut, weil ansonsten vergesse ich immer die Maus im Bild.
Also, was haben wir
am Start? Ich glaube, ich muss gleich nochmal ein Bonbon futtern.
Also, was haben wir am Start? Wir haben einmal
am Start, kriege ich
irgendwie eine gescheite Vorschau.
Wo habe ich denn mein
Tablet? Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz meinen Stream
aufmachen. Auf dem
Tablet.
Damit ich gescheite
Chat-Vorschau habe.
Wenn ich in die andere
Richtung gucke. Sonst funktioniert
das ja nicht. Also,
Wubbelorts
will ich öffnen auf Twitch.
Yes, I
consent. Google Cookies, alles
klar.
Da sind wir doch. Nice.
Da sind wir doch. Sollen wir mal
Breitbild. Wir accepten auch da.
Cookies. Jetzt muss ich mir
erstmal Lost Ark Werbung angucken.
Leute, mal Frage an euch, die
Lost Ark gespielt haben.
Lohnt sich das jetzt noch, sich das zu geben?
Ich meine, das Game ist ja irgendwie seit 6 Jahren
in Korea, oder sind es 8 Jahre, irgendwie 2014
in Korea raus. Was ja
irgendwie lächerlich ist, dass das so lange gedauert
hat, bis das überhaupt hier am Start
ist. Es ist halt die Frage,
ob das ein Game mit Endgame ist.
Oder ob das
halt so ein Game ist, was du durchspielst und dann ist
gut. Ich weiß, dass es ein MMO ist, aber das heißt,
nicht zwangsläufig, dass es ein Game mit Endgame ist, was
ein länger als 2 Monate maximal
bei der Stange hält.
Irgendwie mag
mein iPad
meinen Stream nicht öffnen.
Anzeige ist raus, warum nicht?
Jetzt kommt bestimmt gleich der Chat
so nach dem Motto, lulul, zu viele
Pornhub-Tabs auf, oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das
nicht funktioniert.
Warte mal, ich muss den Stream
aufmachen, sonst kann ich nicht gescheit Vorschau gucken.
Weil ich gucke ja hier, gucke ich ja
Richtung, wie da mein Monitor ist.
Alt-Ewiger-Kreisel-Client, das muss sein.
Nice, jetzt kriege ich nochmal Lost-Ark-Werbung.
Pog, sehr schön, da habe ich drauf gewartet.
Gucken wir uns zweimal Lost-Ark-Werbung an,
alles klar.
Das ist schutz.
Muss man dem Chat nicht zweimal sagen.
So, jetzt habe ich hier das iPad stehen.
Habe ich hier nämlich noch
was, wo ich gucken kann, was der Chat so schreibt.
Da steht das iPad.
Da ist mein, also, also,
da steht das iPad.
Da ist mein Monitor.
So, in die Richtung, da so, da.
Da ist das iPad.
Deswegen, ich gucke in die andere Richtung, sonst sehe ich euch nicht.
Einen guten Anbieter, bei dem man
eine öffentliche IPv4 mieten kann,
um die als VPN zu benutzen.
Ey, du kannst dir, du kannst dir,
tja, Leute, ich muss euch was erzählen.
VPN.
Ich muss euch was erzählen.
Äh,
NordVPN hat bei mir
angefragt, ob, äh,
ich nicht Werbung für sie machen möchte.
Und, da habe ich gesagt,
ja, mein,
ich werde jetzt nichts erzählen, was nicht stimmt.
Aber es hat ja durchaus positive Aspekte,
über die man reden kann. Ja, zum Beispiel,
das, was ich Netflix gucke,
äh, von Serien, die es hier noch nicht gibt
und solche Dinge. Also, das würde ich, das würde ich schon,
würde ich schon prinzipiell machen,
wenn halt so die Rahmenbedingungen stimmen.
Und dann meinten die so, ah ja, nice, nice, nice, machen wir.
Und gestern, und gestern,
gestern, gestern,
antwortet dann einer dort noch per Mail, so nach
dem Motto, ah,
Max, mir ist da noch was
problematisches aufgefallen auf
deinem Channel.
Und da hat er dieses Video hier gefunden.
Easy as fuck.
Ja,
und, äh,
da hat er das Video hier gefunden,
und irgendwie wollen sie jetzt nicht mehr
mit NordVPN.
Das kann ich gar nicht verstehen.
Ich habe jetzt noch angeboten,
naja, ich habe ja in dem Video auch
thematisiert,
dass es durchaus, äh,
sinnvolle Punkte gibt.
Und ich habe, ich würde ja eh nichts
erzählen, wovon ich nicht der Meinung bin,
dass es was bringt. Also,
ich kann das gerne thematisieren.
Mal gucken, ob, mal gucken, ob die wollen.
Aber was ich witzig finde, dass die
ASN einschreiben, dann mit einem was
aushandeln und dann danach auf den
Channel gucken, obwohl die
dich immer anschreiben mit, so nach dem Motto
Max, dein Content ist super, wir gucken
dich schon 300 Jahre. Das schreiben die immer,
das ist Schwachsinn. Ich meine, das weiß jeder, dass es nicht so ist.
Aber das schreiben die alle immer.
Und dann fällt es ihnen doch noch auf.
Hast du eigentlich Patreon oder so?
Ne. Du kannst entweder
Twitch subscriben oder
YouTube subscriben, das geht ja mittlerweile auch.
YouTube kannst du sogar für 2,99
subscriben, für Keksi-Modes, die kannst
du überall auf YouTube verwenden.
Ansonsten kannst du einfach zugucken und nichts machen.
Was hier ist eine Frage, die niemand
bisher gestellt hat. Das Video ist ja schon etwas älter.
Fehlt da nicht das Fragezeichen?
Naja, VPN, kannst du
nix, hab ich doch gesagt, du kannst dir
einen x-beliebigen VPN-Anbieter raussuchen,
wenn du eine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse
haben willst.
Wie das mit Port-Weiterleitung ist, muss man bei denen
auf der Seite gucken, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass
es auch kein Ding ist.
Zumal du ja auch in der Regel
ein 1 zu 1 Mapping hast, also
da musst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel
weiterleiten, sondern nur irgendwas freigeben.
Also ich denke mal, dass
ja, wird auf jeder
Anbieter-Seite stehen.
Ansonsten, wenn der Chat irgendwas weiß
für Michael Fufzspilian, was
ein super Anbieter ist
mit einer öffentlichen IPv4-Adresse. Ich meine, klar,
du kannst ja auch bei Hetzner einen Server mieten und dich
irgendwie tunneln.
Kommt halt immer auf den jeweiligen technischen Skill
und Stand an.
Genau, am besten subs du auf YouTube,
auf Twitch und boostest den Discord-Server.
So ist das. Excellent, excellent.
So muss man das machen. Sehe ich auch so.
Ja, aber
mit Ausrufezeichen Hetzner kriegst du
einen 20-Euro-Startgutschein von mir
und dann ist das Ganze schon wieder viel besser.
Ach nee,
kriegst du ja nicht. Das ist ja
ausgelaufen letztes Jahr.
Geht ja nur bis 31.12.
Sekunde, ich guck mal,
was die geschrieben haben für dieses Jahr.
Ich hab letztens gesagt,
hier lief ja eigentlich ganz gut
letztes Jahr. Wollen wir nicht dieses Jahr
auch mal uns irgendwas überlegen?
Natürlich in der Hoffnung, dass wir neue Konditionen aushandeln
können. Jetzt, wo ich einen Manager hab, der
sich um solche Sachen kümmert, ist das gut. Da muss ich mich
nämlich nicht selbst drum kümmern.
Ähm, aber
ne?
Ich glaub, die haben Urlaub bei Hetzner. Solange sich da
keiner meldet bei Hetzner, gibt's keinen Hetzner-Link.
Da kann man nix machen.
Und auch keine Werbung.
Ich hab wieder komische Anfragen gekriegt
von Dingern, von denen ich im Leben nix
gehört hab.
Keine Ahnung. Na gut.
So, ich mach den Chat mal wieder auf, dass ich euch
sehe. Also, Max hat einen Manager.
Ja, hab ich. Hab ich aber schon vor einer Weile
erzählt, dass ich jemand hab, der sich ein bisschen
um so die Business-Stonks-Sachen kümmert
mittlerweile. Was er übrigens auch
richtig gut macht. Er ist halt super eingespannt.
Er kann sich bei mir jetzt nicht Vollzeit drum kümmern.
Ja, also, wen's interessiert.
Wenn ihr Business-Anfragen habt, könnt ihr euch auch
direkt an ihn wenden. Aber am besten ist weiter,
ihr schreibt dann meine Business-E-Mail-Adresse.
Ja.
Das ist mein Manager.
Die Manager-Diff schlägt
zu.
Da waren wir hier mal ein bisschen größer.
Reicht so ein Tunnel nicht, Google Cloud für... Ja, kannst du auch machen.
Oracle Free,
hier. Das wollten wir... Das Oracle Free
hier wollten wir tatsächlich schon mal seit über
einem Jahr oder so ausprobieren. Woher kennst
du den? Das ist eigentlich ganz witzig, die
Geschichte. Ihr kennt mich ja.
Ich...
lerne nicht freiwillig neue Leute kennen.
Ja. Wie ich heute Morgen auf Twitter...
Wie ich heute Morgen auf Twitter geschrieben hab,
sobald ich mich länger als 10 Minuten mit
echten Leuten auseinandersetzen muss, bin
ich abgefuckt hoch 10. Raste
ich komplett aus.
Und das war ganz witzig. Ich hab
doch mal...
Modern Warfare 2019
Beta-Keys bei mir verlost
auf Twitter. 10 Stück, war das
Glaube. Und der hat damals einen
gewonnen.
Und daraufhin haben wir... Ich mein, ich
hab mir das Profil der Leute ja immer ein bisschen angeguckt,
die die Keys...
mit denen ich die Keys geschickt hab.
Und daraufhin haben wir irgendwie
ein halbes Jahr später oder so. Deswegen
hatte ich den noch in den PNs drinne.
Und irgendwann haben wir ein halbes
Jahr später oder so, hat der irgendwann, glaube ich, mal eine
PN geschrieben. Auch wenn ich ein bisschen MW1'er bin.
Also 2019 spielen wollen.
Nee, nicht halbes
Jahr später. Ziemlich, ziemlich direkt zu
Release, glaube ich, war das schon.
Und da waren doch auch irgendwelche
Valorant-Pros dabei und sowas.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, was machst du denn
sonst so? Dann meinte er, ja, ich manage gerade ein Valorant-Team.
Bin auch so
in dem Bereich aktiv. Und irgendwie
haben wir uns eigentlich ganz gut verstanden und haben uns dann
drauf geeinigt, das wär doch nicht schlecht, wenn
er sich ein bisschen um die Business-Storm-Sachen bei mir
kümmert. Und das funktioniert eigentlich
ganz gut. Ist bei mir auch,
so muss man aber für die IT nicht mit vielen
anderen Leuten kommunizieren. Nee, gerade deswegen
geht man doch an die IT, dass man mehr mit
Technik zu tun hat, weniger mit echten Personen.
Echte Personen gehen mir mega
auf den Sack. Leute, ich sag euch,
letzte Woche, ich hab mehr gemietet, als ich
sinnvolle Sachen gemacht hab. Unglaublich.
Ich glaube, ich hab drei oder, ja, vier Tage
bin ich ja insgesamt da. Ich arbeite ja nur vier Tage die
Woche. Ich hab ohne
Scheiß in diesen
vier Tagen nix gearbeitet. Außer
geschwätzt. Und doch nebenbei
hab ich ein paar Sachen gemacht. Ja, es konnte sich
komplett vergessen. Und kennt ihr diese
Leute? Leute, super, super high-IQ
Meeting, Leute.
Es ist irgendeine Besprechung.
Es sind irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
fünf, sechs Leute eingeladen.
Und ihr fragt euch schon die ganze Zeit,
so, okay, was mach ich hier eigentlich?
Ja, gut, dann kommt mal irgendein Punkt,
wozu ihr was sagen könnt. Da sagt
ihr, ja, wir haben jetzt auch hier so
mal abgegradet und nach dem
Upgrade ist das System 20% schneller
und, boah, eigentlich
ganz okay, was die da gebastelt haben. So,
und dann hast du Leute,
die werden richtig hüppelig,
wenn sie seit 15 Minuten nix gesagt haben.
Und wenn die seit 15 Minuten nix gesagt haben, dann
stellen die so Schein-Zwischenfragen.
Kennt ihr die Leute, die so Schein-Rückfragen
stellen in Meetings? So nach dem
Motto, du sagst, ja, wir haben jetzt geupgradet,
das System ist jetzt 20% schneller.
Und da kommen dann so Rückfragen wie so,
aha, ihr habt das
System geupgradet.
Bedeutet das auch, das System ist jetzt
schneller?
Ja, verstehe,
verstehe. Okay, und was sagt der?
Der Hersteller? Ah, ja, ja.
Einfach nur, einfach nur
so Schein-Rückfragen stellen,
um mal was zu sagen, um wichtig zu erscheinen,
dass man eben seine Anwesenheit
rechtfertigt.
Kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch.
Das ist ganz schlimm. Oder kennt ihr, kennt ihr die
Leute, die
immer exakt so lang
mieten, wie das Meeting eingetragen ist?
So irgendein Typ lädt eine Stunde
ein zum Meeting, du bist nach
20 Minuten fertig und die restlichen
40 Minuten, anstatt zu sagen, ja gut,
haben wir alles besprochen, machen wir was
Sinnvolles, wird dann nochmal das gleiche
durchgekaut oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen
durchgekaut oder erhält irgendeinen Monolog
über eine halbe Stunde, über irgendwelche Dinger,
die er sonst noch so macht.
Das geht dann, wenn der eine Stunde
eingetragen hat, teilweise, dann geht das auch eine Stunde.
Leute, ich muss heute ein bisschen
was trinken zwischendurch.
So, aber
jetzt sind ja alle da im Chat,
sehe ich auch.
Ja,
das sind die meisten Meetings.
Die meisten Meetings könnten eine Teams-Message sein.
Und dann gibt es noch
die Leute, die wegen jedem Scheiß
anrufen, anstatt eine Message zu schreiben.
Kennt ihr die auch? Anstatt zu schreiben,
ah Max, ich hab's ausprobiert, es funktioniert,
callt der dich dann irgendwann
15.40 Uhr
und sagt, ach Max, ich hab's
ausprobiert, es funktioniert.
Die können ja einfach eine Teams-Message schreiben.
Ja, gibt's
genug, ne?
Ich glaub schon, ich glaub,
dass Oracle Free,
Free Tier ist eine VM, die billigste
VM, die sie haben, aber ich mein, Free Tier, ja.
Er macht dir nix draus,
so typisch Andy,
mit den meisten
Buzzwords können auch die Leute, die mit sich
um sich werfen, damit nix anfangen.
Lass dir mal
von einem schlüssig erklären, was Cloud Native
ist. Da geht's los.
Ja,
das stimmt.
Ein Buzzword.
So, aber, jetzt kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen Thema
heute. Ich mach mal hier Fullscreen.
Also, passt mal auf, Leute.
Crashless war auch gut. Was war Crashless?
Das hatten wir letztens im Stream. Genau, Crashless
Update haben wir das letzte Mal gemacht.
Ja, Patrick, so
ungefähr würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch
umschreiben. Also, eine Applikation, die
entwickelt wurde, explizit, um in der Cloud
zu laufen, eben mit Technologien, die dort
besonders gut zur Geltung kommen und
nichts, was man so quasi noch
von alt auf Cloud umzieht. So irgendwie
in der Richtung, wenn ich, ja, wahrscheinlich würde ich das auch
so beschreiben. Kann man,
ja, ist immer Definition,
mache. Und wisst ihr, was ich auch geil finde, was bei uns
super auf der Arbeit immer ist?
Kennt ihr Projekte, die scheitern?
Also, bei uns gibt es keine Projekte, die
scheitern oder Projekte, die, die
kein gutes Ergebnis haben.
Bei uns sind alle Projekte immer super
zufriedenstellend, werden die abgeschlossen.
Also, bei uns gibt es keine Projekte, die fehlschlagen.
Was wir machen ist,
wir definieren
kurz vor Projektende aus den
100%, 20%
raus und sagen, das sind die neuen
100%.
Also, man macht, man macht quasi nur
ein Fünftel und sagt dann
am Ende, das Fünftel ist aber eigentlich
jetzt 100%. Und dann sind
die Projekte immer super erfolgreich fertig.
Das Five Head, Five Head.
Learnings, ja, Learnings hat man daraus immer
ganz viel mitgenommen. Bei uns sagt
man aber nicht Learnings, bei uns sagt man, das ist
auch so eine Redewendung bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Wir kennen jetzt die Schwächen,
sagen sie bei uns immer. Wir
kennen jetzt die Schwächen.
Das ist auch so ein absolutes Füllwort. Das kannst
du bei uns theoretisch überall,
überall einwerfen und alle sagen so,
ah, okay, wir kennen jetzt die Schwächen, okay, okay,
next, nächstes Thema, please.
Die Schwächen, das ist doch egal von was. Wir
kennen jetzt die Schwächen. Du darfst bei solchen
Sachen nicht erwarten, dass es irgendwie Sinn
ergibt. Das ist genau
das Gleiche, wie auf irgendwelchen
Meetings immer gesagt wird,
ah, da sind wir dran oder ah,
das nehme ich mit. Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Da geht es nicht darum, um was Sinnvolles
zu sagen. Da geht es darum, dass die Leute sagen, okay,
ich hake das jetzt in meinem Protokoll
ab. Wiedervorlage, nächste
Woche und tschüss.
Geht es nicht darum, dass da wirklich was passiert?
Als würdest du da irgendwas mitnehmen oder als würdest
du an irgendwas dran sein?
So, jetzt aber. Jetzt kommen wir mal zur
eigentlichen Geschichte heute.
Setzt du jetzt Unraid bei dir
zu Hause ein? Noch nicht. Noch habe ich meine
hier hinten im Serverraum, das steht
so da, so steht das dann.
Übrigens, die Katze hat heute zugeschlagen.
Guck mal.
Zählt das schon auf
Twitch unter Selbstverletzung? Ich werde jetzt gebannt.
Ich habe mich ja nicht selbst verletzt. Die Katze hat mich
verletzt. Ja, also aktuell habe ich da
hinten im Serverraum, da, da so,
habe ich noch mein
Low-Power-Intel-Kiste stehen, aber ich probiere
Unraid auf der Kiste jetzt noch ein bisschen aus.
Also,
Handleak, ja, wir gucken uns das
mal zusammen an, was wir
so hier am Start haben. Also, hier haben wir einmal
einen,
ich hoffe, man sieht das jetzt
gescheit,
einen HP Microserver Generation
10 Plus.
Das Ding ist aber auch schon zwei Jahre alt, wo es sich um die
rausgekommen ist. Das ist nicht mal das allerneueste.
Aber ich habe gedacht, man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts.
Wir gucken da auch gleich rein,
weil wir müssen ein bisschen was umbauen.
Oder was einbauen oder so. Standardmäßig
hat der,
ich glaube hier vorne, bin ich mir nicht
sicher, müssen wir gucken, ich glaube hier vorne,
vier Einschübe für Festplatten
und hinten,
Sekunde, mal gucken, ob man das jetzt sieht.
Und hinten hast
du
einen PCI-Express,
PCI-Express,
PCI-Express Low-Profile-Steckplatz,
einen ILO-Steckplatz
und eine
ich weiß nicht, ob die austauschbar ist,
ehrlich gesagt, aber wahrscheinlich, wenn da so eine
Schraube drüber ist,
vier Netzwerk-Ports.
Was ziemlich
cool ist, habe ich mir überlegt mit den vier
Netzwerk-Ports, weil
ich werde da drauf wahrscheinlich
eins, zwei VMs laufen
lassen und die VMs kriegen einfach
ihr eigenes Netzwerk-Interface.
Da gehst du einigen Problemen
aus dem Weg. Das glaube ich
ganz praktisch. So, und dann hat man hier neben,
hier neben hat man
VGA,
HDMI, USB,
USB 3.
Äh,
Moment, ich muss es korrekt
benennen,
USB 3.2
Gen 1,
das ist
Displayport?
Oh, tatsächlich,
Displayport. Ha, das wird
schwierig anzuschließen. Ich muss erstmal einen Displayport
zur HDMI-Adapter gleich suchen.
Das wird Painschamp.
Äh, sag mal bitte
die genaue Bezeichnung. Für was?
Doch, doch, das ist Displayport.
Du hast recht, das ist ein Displayport.
Eindeutig ist das ein Displayport. Achso.
Nee, das ist
ein Monitor.
Guck mal, da ist oben ein Monitor drüber abgebildet.
Das ist Displayport. Das ist ein Displayport.
Ich muss gleich mal ein Displayport auf HDMI-Kabel
suchen oder was in der Richtung, weil sonst habe ich
echt ein Problem, das gleich anzuschließen.
Da ist ein
Monitor oben drüber. Guck, das ist Display 1.
Hier, und das muss Displayport
sein. Der Server, äh,
das ist ein HP... Hier, nimm den QR-Code.
Scan den QR-Code.
Da müsste es eigentlich stehen.
Ähm,
das ist
ein HP
Microserver Gen 10+,
die Variante mit dem
Xeon drin. Viele Varianten gibt es davon nicht.
Also, das hier ist ein...
Kein Managementport.
Den Managementport...
Den Managementport
kann man hier oben reinmachen. Guck mal.
Hier oben ist...
Hier oben, man kann
ein ILO-Kit kaufen für 40 Euro
oder so. Aber ich habe es jetzt erstmal gelassen.
Ich meine,
das Ding
steht 5 Meter hinter mir in einem kleinen
Abstellkämmerchen. Da brauche ich, glaube ich, kein ILO.
So. Ähm...
Dann haben wir hier...
USB...
4 Stück. USB
Gen 3. Äh,
nein. USB 3.2
Gen 1.
Und hier vorne
haben wir
nochmal, wie ihr
hier seht, haben wir USB
Gen 3.2
2 mal
1, 1 mal 2.
Scheiß
auf USB-Benahmung, Alter.
Klasse, das USB-Forum, dass die sich so eine Scheiße
ausgedacht haben.
Ne. Also, das hier vorne sind 10 Gigabit-Ports
und das hinten sind
5 Gigabit-Ports.
Und angeblich hat der Onboard noch ein USB-2
zum Booten, was ich ziemlich cool finde.
So. Ähm...
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Ich zeige nochmal kurz die andere Hardware, die ich habe.
Also, was ich mir gekauft habe hierfür...
Zeige ich mal. Also, ich habe noch
ein paar Sachen, die ich schon eine Weile
hier rumliegen habe, die ich jetzt dafür verwenden werde.
Also, was ich mir dafür gekauft habe, ist einmal
die Kiste hier neu
und gebraucht von Ebay, weil ich mit den
Dingern gute Erfahrungen gemacht habe,
eine
weitere 10 Gigabit-Karte.
Das ist eine...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das da steht. Doch.
Hier, Melanox.
China-Chinesen-Hersteller.
Also, made in China.
Ein Melanox Connect
X3-EM.
Es ist eine
Low-Profile-Taukenspiele.
Das ist eine unglaubliche 10-Gigabit-Karte.
Das ist das, was ich haben will.
Low-Profile, weil...
Da, guck, da Low-Profile-Bracket.
So, und das sollte
dann theoretisch da reinpassen.
Das gucken wir uns an. Wir machen das Ding jetzt auf und gucken rein.
Wie viel zieht das Strom?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das werden wir ausprobieren. Da ist ja schon das Teil.
Aber wir machen das jetzt erstmal auf und bauen ein.
Und bauen die 10-Gigabit-Adapter ein.
Erstmal gucken, wie ich das aufkriege.
So.
Chat.
Pass auf. Zeig mal her.
Ah ja. Ich würde mal sagen,
da dran muss man drehen.
Gucken wir mal.
Jetzt wird das natürlich toll. Ich muss es so machen,
dass ihr seht. Das heißt, ich selbst
kann nicht richtig hingucken.
Schauen wir mal. So.
Ich mache das jetzt
über die Kamera.
Weil ich selbst nicht hingucken kann.
Mab. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge Pock.
So.
Ah.
Okay.
Nice. Das ist einfach.
Ich mag das immer, wenn Gehäuse easy gehen, ohne
dass man sich irgendwie in die Finger schneidet.
Also. Was haben wir denn
hier zu bieten?
Sieht sehr kompakt aus.
Ich hoffe, ihr könnt da irgendwie reingucken.
Wir haben 16-Gigabyte-RAM
drin.
Ich habe noch einen zweiten
8-Gigabyte und einen zweiten 16-Gigabyte-Riegel
rumfliegen
von einer anderen Kiste.
Ich werde es aber jetzt erstmal so lassen,
im Auslieferungszustand, wie es ist.
Die kannst du auf 20-Gigabit
per Firmware hochtakten.
Die...
Die USB-Ports?
Oder was?
Was ist das für eine Bezahlung?
Ich glaube 700 Euro.
Brian, schick mal einen Link dazu, wie man das
hochtaktet.
Naja. Zumindest haben wir hier einmal 16-Gigabyte-RAM
drin.
Also ich finde,
es ist preis-leistungstechnisch durchaus in Ordnung.
So, da sieht man hier hinten einen CPU.
Ein CPU-Kühler drin.
Hier oben sind die Drive-Base
für die Festplatten vermutlich mal stark.
Ach, guck mal hier unten. Da ist er.
Seht ihr? Hier. Da ist der interne
USB 2.
Stecker.
So,
wie kriegen wir das jetzt auf?
Also hier hinten ist die Netzwerk...
Wir müssen irgendwie an den PCI-Express-Slot
und
so, guck hier. Da ist PCI-Express, Leute.
Seht ihr? Da ist der PCI-Express-Slot.
An den kommen wir jetzt auf jeden Fall
nicht so einfach ran. Wir müssen das Ding irgendwie
aufmachen. So. Gucken wir erst mal, wie man das
vorne aufkriegt.
Ah, guck mal da.
Logs.
Ach hier, schaut mal. Da.
Seht ihr das?
Da ist sowas.
Okay.
Ich hab's.
Entlockt.
Ne, ich hab's gelockt.
Es war entlockt.
Jetzt ist entlockt.
So, und auf der anderen Seite ist auch
entlockt. Alles klar.
Und kann ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt vorne
abmachen dadurch, oder wie?
Ah ja. Aha.
Blende ab.
Ah, guck mal da.
Wir haben
vier Laufwerks-Slots.
Vier Laufwerks-Slots.
Ich hol mal kurz eine Festplatte
zum ausprobieren.
So.
Kommt da RGB rein?
Ja, muss für mehr FPS-Boost.
So, mal gucken, wie das hier funzt.
Also, zeigt mal kurz her.
So.
Von der Idee her,
seht ihr da hinten die Anschlüsse?
Also sind zwei, sind zwei Stück pro Seite.
Ob der Hotswap
fähig ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube,
offiziell sagen sie, nein, es ist
nicht Hotswap fähig.
Einfach?
Ohne irgendwelche Laufwerksdinger rein?
Nee, oder?
Brauchen wir dafür irgendwelche
Laufwerksrollen
oder so?
Wie funzt das?
Die Schrauben vorne sind für...
Ah, guckte mal da.
Das hier ist für die Festplatten die Schraube.
Das ist ja richtig Big Brain. Guck mal da.
Das ist die Schraube für die Festplatten,
so dass die besser, dass die in die Schienen passen.
Das ist clever. Das finde ich gut.
Schrauben wir, dann
schraube ich mir mal eine dieser Schrauben oder
vier Schrauben mal raus.
Weil,
naja,
sonst kriege ich die Festplatte ja nicht rein, ne?
So, erste Schraube.
Vier,
ich vermute mal vier Stück pro Platte.
Falls ich da richtig liege.
Bei HP sind da
richtig schlaue Menschen unterwegs.
Ja, ich finde es gut, dass sie das so
gemacht haben und dass man nicht irgendein extra Tütchen
braucht, was man direkt verliert.
So, dann nehmen wir mal die
Festplatte jetzt. Die habe ich da hinten hingeschmissen.
So, von der Idee
her heißt das also,
man nimmt die Festplatte, wenn mir die jetzt
runterfällt, die Platte ist übrigens RIP
wahrscheinlich. So, und dann machen wir jetzt
einfach mal hier.
Tatsächlich, guck mal da.
Passt, easy.
Die muss man wahrscheinlich gar nicht so fest anschrauben.
Brauchen wir mal kurz
einen anderen.
Der passt nicht, der ist zu klein.
So, dann machen wir erstmal hier die Schrauben gerade.
Ich will die Festplatte wahrscheinlich eh nicht da drin haben.
Aber ich will mal die Laufwerks-
Schächte ausprobieren.
So, andere Seite.
Ich hoffe ihr seht, seht ihr was?
Ja, ne?
Müsst ihr das eigentlich sehen.
Ja, ich sehe es auch in der
Vorschau, man sieht halbwegs was.
Die Schrauben sind
gut. Die Schrauben verkanten sich nicht.
Oftmals verkanten sich
diese Billigschrauben bei Festplatten.
Wie heißen diese?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie diese Anschlüsse heißen.
Also die Standardschrauben, die so ziemlich
in jedem Gehäuse drin sind.
Die verkanten sich bei so Billig-China-Chinesen-Schrauben
immer ganz gerne.
So, jetzt haben wir die Festplatte prepared.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal.
So.
Und.
Plutsch.
Da ist er drin.
Hey, das ist easy.
So, jetzt müssen wir die
aufmachen und wieder rausziehen, oder?
Aber wie kriegt man die wieder raus?
So nicht.
Habe ich das jetzt falsch gemacht?
Ne. Ah, man muss, guckt mal.
Guckt mal, man muss ein bisschen.
Man muss fester drücken.
So geht's rein, jetzt kann man so machen, guckt.
Dann geht's wieder raus.
Das ist gut gemacht.
Find ich nice.
71 Watt TDP.
Ja, das ist doch vollkommen egal, was der hat,
wenn er brummt.
So, Festplatte drin.
Die lasse ich wieder raus.
Wobei, die lasse ich drin.
Wir brauchen ja gleich was zum testen.
Ne, ich mache die raus.
Ich drehe den Server jetzt noch ein bisschen rum
und wir gucken zusammen.
So, Festplatte am Start. Easy.
Die Karte hat aber nur SFP+.
Ach, du meinst nicht
USB übertakten.
Du meinst die Netzwerkkarte
übertakten. Ne, wozu?
Mein Switch kann ja plus 10G, warum soll ich die übertakten?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Max, deine Hose wieder.
Wieso?
Hier, da.
Ahnfarbe.
Stelzmodus.
Will ich, dass ihr meine Hose seht.
Gachi Bass.
So.
Hehehe.
So, jetzt haben wir die Netzwerke.
Wie kriegen wir die Netzwerkkarte rein?
Hm, also Festplatte habe ich
jetzt gecheckt, wie das funktioniert.
Die große
Preisfrage ist,
wie kommen wir an diesen,
da, an diesen
PCI Express Port.
Also, was wahrscheinlich schon mal nicht funktioniert,
ist so.
Weil, ich muss ja hier,
ah ne, ihr seht ja gar nichts,
ähm, weil, ich muss ja hier
an das Slotblech dran, was da auf der
Seite ist. Hm.
Wie geht das
Ding auf?
Also, wir müssen,
ja, da dran.
Da, an den Slot.
Da müssen wir dran.
Manual lesen. Ne,
das habe ich weggeschmissen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das ist.
Ich hab kein
Manual.
Bevor wir was machen, rüsten wir
erstmal die Netzwerkkarte um zu Low Profile,
würde ich sagen. Und hoffen, dass
es reinpasst.
Ah Mist, zu groß.
Gut, dass ich immer zwei Stück da hab.
Ah.
Eins.
Nächste Schraube.
Wisst ihr was?
Warum mache ich denn das auf der Kiste oben drauf?
Die Kiste kommt mal weg und wir
schrauben das hier um.
Klickt doch sonst keiner durch.
Man liest kein Manual richtig.
Also, wenn ich das Ding nicht aufkriege,
wird tatsächlich gegoogelt.
Ich google dann einfach, äh,
Open Microserver
Gen 10 Plus.
Da sind doch
Bilder für das Systemboard Removal.
Ja, tatsächlich. Guck mal da.
Okay.
HiIQ Chat.
Was sehe ich da?
Äh.
Ich muss schrauben hinten.
Ich muss dann...
Ah, hinten sind angeblich...
Sind da Schrauben?
Ach, guck mal da.
Seht ihr? Da, guck mal. Schrauben.
Das ist 16G mit dem Xeon, ja.
Da sind Schrauben. Die macht man auf
und dann...
Geht man einfach dran. Okay.
Ich werde
das überprüfen, ob das funktioniert.
Ich hab noch
ein zweites 16G
RAM-Modul und ein 8 GB RAM-Modul.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich noch einbauen, aber
nicht on stream. Jetzt guck ich mir das erstmal
in Ruhe an. So, also.
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Wie kam das jetzt hin?
So, ne?
So?
Ehh.
Chat, mache ich das richtig?
Ist das so richtig?
Ja?
So?
Oder...
Oder muss das oben drauf?
Ne, das ist glaube ich schon richtig.
Ich meine, man sollte davon ausgehen,
weil ich mal Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
gelernt habe. Ich weiß,
wie man das Slot-Plech von einer Netzwerkkarte
tauscht, aber da täuscht...
täuscht euch mal nicht, was ich da noch weiß.
Ich mach das mal kurz weg, sonst ist das zu unscharf.
Wer weiß denn auch so was?
Oh, Mist!
Huh! Beinahe wäre mir die Schraube runtergefallen.
Wie kriegt man das denn jetzt hier...
Ich glaube, der ist nicht magnetisch, den ich hier hab.
Okay. Und pass auf,
wir müssen High-IQ machen. Der ist magnetisch.
Ist er nicht?
Okay.
Die Schrauben sind nicht
magnetisch, glaube ich, weil normalerweise
ist der magnetisch. Ja, ja.
Der ist magnetisch, aber die Schrauben sind
nicht magnetisch. Das sind Billy-China-Chinesen-Schrauben,
die sind nicht magnetisch. Okay.
Hallo, Schrauben.
Vielleicht ist das die High-Performance-
Netzwerk-Karten-Schraube.
Die darf nicht magnetisch sein,
wegen Interferenzen oder
China-Logik.
Was weiß ich?
So, guck mal.
Wo ist das Loch? Gachi-Bass.
Ich seh nix, das ist zu weit weg.
Boomer-Augen.
So.
Gut. Netzwerkkarte
umgebaut. Alles klar.
Jetzt machen wir mal komplett
weg.
Okay, Kiste wieder her.
Also, was soll ich machen?
Ich soll die Schrauben hinten raus machen
und
dann dran ziehen, sagen die Bilder
zumindest. Also, Schrauben
raus machen. Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das stimmt,
was da steht. Okay, Schrauben
raus.
Deswegen mag ich übrigens diese
Silikonmatte. Man verliert
deutlich weniger Schrauben.
Musst auf die Netzwerkkarte als
Userbericht schreiben, die ferromagnetischen
Eigenschaften der mitgelieferten
Schrauben lassen zu wünschen übrig.
Pfeifert-Satz. Ja.
Das machen wir Amazon-Bewertung, mach ich
nachher.
Konnte nicht einbauen.
Äh.
Katze hat Schraube verschluckt. Eins von
fünf.
Oder irgendwas.
Okay, nice.
So, und jetzt?
Und jetzt zie...
Hm. Ah.
Ah. Oh.
Guckt mal hier. Guckt euch das mal an,
wie gut das funktioniert.
Alter. Massive.
Six-Kopf. Alter. Guckt euch das mal an.
Hi-HQ-Konstruktion.
Das ist ja...
Das ist wirklich... Also.
Da reicht ein fünfer Kopf nicht
mehr. Das muss schon ein sechser Kopf sein.
Das ist
nice. Das ist cool. Das mag ich.
So könnten alle ihre
Gehäuse aufbauen.
Stellt euch das mal vor. So ein normales Desktop-
Gehäuse mit einfach einem rausslidebaren
Mainboard-Schlitten. Wär das
nicht nice?
Na, eigentlich braucht man das nicht. Aber trotzdem. Wäre schon.
Wäre schon gut. Aber das ist cool.
Das ist nice.
Front-Server. Ich... Okay.
Hier muss ich nichts machen. Das ist ja fertig geworden.
Hier oben. Hier oben kann man übrigens
das ILO reinmachen, weil man sich ein ILO-Kit
gekauft hat. Ich hab kein ILO-Kit gekauft.
Und hier unten ist PCI-Express.
Das heißt, von der Idee her,
was muss ich denn jetzt machen? Ich muss
PCI-Express die Schraube
rausmachen. Ich muss aufpassen,
dass ich das Kidsdent runter schmeiß hier.
PCI-Express,
Schraube raus.
PCI-Express, Schraube raus.
Die Schrauben sind gut. Also,
das sind gescheite Schrauben. Nicht, dass
es viel kosten würde, aber es haben so viele Gehäuse
Schrott-Schrauben dabei. Unglaublich.
Was es gekostet hat,
äh, also irgendwas um 700
Euro in der Ausstattung. Deswegen, ich hab übrigens
auch hier einen mit SSD genommen.
Nicht, weil ich das haben wollte mit
SSD, sondern weil, zahlt euch
jetzt bei Amazon, der mit SSD
drinne,
40 Euro günstiger war, als der
ohne SSD drinne. Und ansonsten
komplett gleich.
Also, sag ich mal, warum soll ich denn ohne SSD
nehmen, wenn es teurer ist?
Amazon-Logik.
Leute, ihr müsst mich ans Trinken
erinnern, sonst tut mir wieder der Hals weh später.
Für welchen Zweck wird der Rechner
eingesetzt? Stream Entertainment.
Ne, ich werd
Unraid drauf installieren.
Ich bin ja kein großer Unraid-Fan
gewesen, die letzten Jahre über.
Aber,
ich hab mir das letztens angeguckt und hab mir gedacht,
ist eigentlich ein ganz nices System.
Mit relativ wenig
Magic im Hintergrund.
Wenn man sich das ein bisschen anguckt,
fand ich eigentlich gut.
Und dann dachte ich mir, bei der Gelegenheit
kann ich mir doch einfach mal ein bisschen neue
Hardware gönnen und es da drauf laufen lassen.
Gibt es auch einen M2-Anschluss?
Nein. Leider nicht.
Er hat einen internen USB, aber
es gibt leider keinen M2.
Deswegen, ich zeige euch gleich, was ich sonst noch
da hab, müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Ist das ähnlich wie Proxmox? Ey, Proxmox kannst du
da drauf auch betreiben, gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Proxmox ist halt eine
Virtualisierungslösung.
Und Unraid ist also
hauptsächlich eine Virtualisierungslösung.
Mit allen notwendigen Features dafür.
Unraid ist erstmal eine NAS mit
on top Container und Virtualisierung.
Also, wenn man hauptsächlich
auf Virtualisierung steht,
und irgendeinen Open Source
KVM Hypervisor haben will,
dann ist Proxmox
eine sinnvolle Sache. Ansonsten einfach
ESX drauf und gut ist.
Open Media Vault,
ja, Open Media Vault mochte
ich nicht wirklich.
Wo ist die SSD verbaut? Hier vorne
in den Laufwerkschächten.
Das, was schon drinnen gesteckt hat.
So, wir probieren jetzt erstmal die...
Wo ist denn die Netzwerkkarte überhaupt?
Aha, ok.
Also,
wie komme ich...
Leute, ich muss sagen, ich mag die Konstruktion.
Die ist simpel.
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht besser zeigen,
weil das ein bisschen wackelig ist.
Aber guckt mal, hier geht einfach
die Slotpläne kommt easy raus.
Und ich denke mal, ich kann jetzt
einfach die Netzwerkkarte nehmen
und hier einführen
in den Schlitz.
Und dann
müsste das einfach funktionieren.
Pok, fertig!
Easy!
Das ist ein gutes System.
Ich trage heute kein Holz bei der Hemd.
Ich habe hier so ein billiges...
Billiges...
Was ist denn das?
So ein
ärmelloses...
ärmelloses drüberziehen Ding.
Keine Ahnung.
So, und jetzt schrauben wir das einfach.
Also, ich muss sagen, das System gefällt mir echt gut.
Das ist mit ein paar
Handgriffen gemacht.
Du reißt dir kein Bein aus, du schneidest dich
aus dem Licht, wie bei manchen billigen Sachen.
Du tust dir nicht weh, wie bei
manchen fetten Rechenzentrumskisten.
Nice!
Also, das gefällt mir wirklich gut.
Jetzt machen wir es rein
und guckt mal hier.
Klips, klips.
Und schon haben wir hier
unsere Netzwerkkarte drin.
10G, easy as fuck.
Guckt da.
10G am Start.
So einfach kann es sein.
Irgendwas um 700 Euro.
So.
Jetzt. Ah, jetzt muss ich
hinten erstmal zu.
Lasst mal kurz überlegen.
Ich zeige euch mal kurz die andere
Hardware, die ich dafür noch zur Verfügung habe.
Die habe ich jetzt nicht extra dafür gekauft.
Die habe ich noch zum größten Teil.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob wir da was einbauen
beziehungsweise was wir davon verwenden.
Ich zeige es euch nur mal kurz.
Mal kurz hier weg.
Ähm.
Also, was ich habe ist,
ich habe einmal einen SanDisk
USB Stick.
Den hat mir der Chat empfohlen sogar.
Chat hat gesagt, es ist gut, soll ich verwenden dafür.
Ich habe mir gedacht, Chat, ich glaube
euch, wir wissen ja, der Chat
ist mittlerweile durch die ganzen Zapps so unglaublich
high IQ, der kann eigentlich kein Mist
empfehlen, USB Stick. Und nur
für den Fall der Fälle, dass dieser
USB Stick aus welchen Gründen auch immer,
weil ich habe gelesen, Unraid
funktioniert nur mit bis maximal
32 Gigabyte. Aber das kann ich mir nicht sagen.
Weil ich meine, warum sollte ein aktuelles
also, bescheuert.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Habe ich noch einen alten
16 Gigabyte USB Stick
ausgebuddelt.
So, das brauchen wir gleich zum System installieren.
Dann habe ich noch zu bieten
eine
Die habe ich schon eine Weile.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich damit machen sollte.
Deswegen vielleicht ist das eine gute Sache hierfür.
Ich habe noch eine SanDisk
SanDisk Extreme Portable
USB SSD.
Die können wir als Cache verwenden dafür.
Weil,
weil ich habe mir überlegt,
da ist zwar eine SSD drinnen,
aber die SSD ist ja nur
per SATA angebunden.
Und theoretisch
ist 10 Gigabit USB
schneller als
SATA.
Kaufst du dir das ILO Kit noch nach?
Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ich habe das
das ganze Zeug
einen Meter hinter mir
also jetzt von hier 2 Meter
hinter mir
in so einem Miniserver Raum stehen
und
ja
eigentlich brauchst du Strom
und ich brauch es nicht.
Das ist keine Festplatte, das ist eine SSD.
Steht doch da. Guck mal da.
SR Portable SSD
Das ist keine
HDD
Da ist eine SSD drinnen.
Hier vorne ist eine SSD drinnen im Server.
Das ist eine, ich kann es euch zeigen.
Das ist eine, zumindest habe ich das gekauft
mit SSD.
Zumindest habe ich das gekauft mit einer SSD drinnen.
Schauen wir mal, ob da wirklich eine SSD drinnen ist.
Da, hier guck mal.
Das da.
Oh.
Habe ich doch nicht gekauft mit einer SSD.
Ist das
eine SSD oder ist das eine Festplatte?
Das sieht nicht aus wie
eine SSD, ne?
Gerade hier oben
mit diesen Platten und so, das sieht nicht aus
wie eine SSD.
Ja gut.
Useless, brauche ich nicht.
Also mal davon abgesehen, ich habe die ja gar nicht
wirklich bestellt.
Ich habe
ähm
die Version gekauft, wo eine
ich dachte SSD dabei ist.
Die war aber
40 Euro günstiger als die ohne.
Also ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich da großartig was verschenkt oder so.
Was ist denn das? Ist das eine
ST1000
DM010
HDD
bei Seagate Technologies?
Okay, Leute.
Das ist doch keine SSD.
Ich bekomme aber, alles klar.
Ist aber auch egal, die brauche ich nicht.
Die kann ich, die mache ich gleich weg.
Die werde ich nicht verwenden.
Das ist nicht eine SMR Platte.
Ist SMR das, wo sich die
wo sich die Ringe überlagern?
Das glaube ich nicht, oder?
Das bei einem 1 TB SMR ist?
1 TB ist so ein Ding, das machen die quasi
Morgens
beim Frühstücken haben die das quasi schon.
Würdet ihr nicht empfehlen
einen USB-Device in den Cache
oder das Array zu packen, da sich die
USB-ID bei jedem Boot ändern kann?
Zwar unwahrscheinlich, wenn immer die gleichen Geräte angeschlossen sind,
aber nur alleine eine Maus anschließen kann?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Es mag sich
die Bus-ID, was du meinst, ändern.
Das ist aber egal,
weil
Linux ist ja nicht dumm,
was das angeht.
Du hast ja hier
DEV
USB
Ne, ist es
PROC-USB? Ach Mist.
DEV
USB? Ne, ach was ist es?
PROC-USB?
DEV
BY-ID? USB BY-ID?
Wo ist das denn hier?
Also du hast
das nicht nur nach Bus-ID, sondern auch nach Seriennummer
und sowas und die ändert sich
nicht.
BUS BUS
Ne, ach Mist, ich finde es nicht.
USB BY-ID Linux
SUS BUS
Ok
USB
Wo ist denn
der Mist?
Man konnte das Ding doch entweder BY-ID,
bei Seriennummer, bei sonst was
Ach DEV DISK
Ja, das meine ich
genau.
Das hast du BY-ID, das hast du BY-LABEL,
BY-PARTITION, BY-PASS
oder BY-UID.
Und das ändert sich nicht.
Und soweit ich das letzte Mal gesehen habe,
ist Android relativ schlau
und nimmt das auch per
ID, die sich nicht ändert.
Also da muss man sich, denke ich, keine
Gedanken machen.
Ok.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich habe euch
die SSD gezeigt. Ach ja.
Und ich habe noch eine andere Option.
Da darf der Chat jetzt entscheiden, was wir nehmen.
Wobei,
wir probieren einfach beides aus.
Wir haben ja performance-technisch, können wir das ja mal testen.
Also, ähm
ich mach das Ding mal kurz weg.
Also wir haben zur Auswahl einmal
also das hier
ist für System, zum Android installieren
eins davon nehmen wir.
Dann
haben wir als SSD-Cache
das Ding oder
oder
anstatt dem hätte ich
auch noch diese Kombination hier zu bieten.
Das ist etwas neuer, das habe ich mir noch
vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mal zugelegt.
Ich habe eine
2TB
EVO
und ich habe noch ein
M2 zu USB
Enclosure.
Jetzt ist die Frage, Chat, was nehmen wir davon?
Wir nehmen, ganz ehrlich, wir nehmen beide.
Ich probiere einfach beides aus.
Also rein von
der Zuverlässigkeit, da dürfte das hier
eine Ecke besser sein.
Max hat zum Ende
des Monats kein Geld mehr, klar.
Ich gebe nie was aus.
Ich gebe so gut wie nie
was aus. Und wenn ich
was ausgebe, dann ab und zu mal für ein bisschen Technik-Scheiß.
Ich habe wirklich
keinerlei Probleme, was
das angeht.
Der einzige Grund,
warum ich immer mal wieder meinen Chef
nerve wegen mehr Geld ist,
nicht so sehr, weil ich mir denke,
Mist, ich komme nicht über die Runden,
sondern weil ich nicht will,
dass das
so billig wird für den Arbeitgeber.
Weil ich sehe, was es
umliegend teilweise für Kohle gibt,
für Stellen, die das machen, was ich mache
oder das machen, was
Kollegen von mir machen. Und ich sehe es nicht ein,
dass sie bei uns irgendwie mit
nur 2 Drittel des Gehalts wegkommen.
Das kann ja nicht sein. Das ist für alle schlecht, weil
wir haben definitiv Leute, da weiß ich, die brauchen das.
Geld und das Schöne ist, wenn
einer mehr bekommt, kommen alle mehr.
Zumindest stimmt so nicht, das stimmt
nicht, aber es ist dann potenziell
einfacher. Okay.
Man fährt so einen
dicken Porsche. Nein, ihr wisst genau, was
ich für ein Auto fahre, Chat.
Das ist weit entfernt
von irgendwas Sportlichem.
Das ist sehr agil.
So, das war's, Leute. Also das ist die
Hardware. Ich bin nur gerade
am überlegen, kann man
vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht
kann man
irgendwas da von innen rein machen.
Da müssen wir mal schauen.
Kann man, also hier ist
übrigens, hier ist übrigens der
USB-Stick, von dem wir booten.
Ich leg das mal kurz weg.
Und ich schraube,
Leute, ich schraube,
ich schraube erstmal hinten wieder zu, weil ich kenn mich.
Ich kenn mich.
Ich heb das Ding gleich hoch und mir rutscht hinten
das Ding raus, fällt auf die Erde und ist kaputt.
Deswegen schraube ich, äh, Moment,
falsch rum. Da muss ich zuschrauben.
Der Chat, dem Chat würde das
natürlich gefallen.
Der würde dann sowas schreiben wie, he doesn't know,
he lacks critical information oder irgendwie
sowas. Kurz, ich, ich kann's mir
richtig vorstellen. Ich weiß genau, wie das
im Chat läuft. Ich würde das Ding hochheben,
ja, ich würde das Ding so hochheben
und die Leute im Chat würden sehen, gleich
fällt dem Max das Ding raus
und der Chat würde dann
nicht sagen, Max, Achtung,
gleich fällt das Ding raus, sondern
die würden machen, people laugh,
he lacks critical information
und würden warten, bis das Ding mir runterfällt.
Soll der
deinen Server ablösen? Ja, vielleicht.
Vielleicht.
He doesn't know.
Das ist so,
so hab ich das erwartet, ja.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass es jetzt
Schwachsinn ist, was ihr schreibt, weil er
knowt, er knowt.
He knows, he doesn't lack critical information.
Okay.
Ist das das richtige Loch?
Hä?
Nein! Die Schraube ist weg.
Ich hab sie noch gefangen. Bam.
Warum geht das nicht
richtig rein? Was ist das hier?
Was ist das? Warum geht das nicht?
Zack. Muss ich mal genauer hingucken.
Er knowt.
Ja, er knowt.
Ah, ich hab in die falsche Richtung gedreht.
Profis
am Werk.
Umu, das überlasse ich deiner Fantasie.
So, alles drin,
alles dran.
Mein Opa hätte jetzt gesagt, oder besser gesagt, meine Oma hätte gesagt,
sitzt, bast, wackelt
und hat Luft.
Nur, dass es keine Luft hat.
He lacks critical information.
Ich lecke keine critical
information mehr.
Oh Leute, ich krieg Kopfweh.
Von der Impfung heute.
Und mir tut der Arm weh.
Die Antenne ist bald da.
So, jetzt ist die Frage.
Also, ich muss
auf jeden Fall
die
SSD irgendwo
hier vorne
an den USBs anschließen, weil
die USBs hier vorne
sind 10 Gigabit.
Die Sache ist jetzt nur die,
kann ich das nicht irgendwie hier reinlegen?
Moment, ich pack das mal kurz aus.
Wir packen
den Kram mal kurz aus hier.
Wie geht denn das?
Ich mag so Dinger nicht, die schlecht aufgehen.
Muss alles
ohne
großen Kraftaufwand
öffnenbar sein.
So, also haben wir einmal eine SanDisk.
Guck mal, das ist ein ziemlich kleines Teil.
Und wir haben
einen USB-Kabel. Was ist das für ein hässliches USB-Kabel?
Was?
Hydra!
Haben wir das
Emote dafür?
Achso, das ist ein Adapter.
Jetzt erkenne ich das.
Das ist irgendwie...
Okay, naja, das ist...
Das ist dumm.
Da muss ich ein anderes Kabel nehmen.
Ich habe noch eins.
Ich habe hier irgendwo einen
USB-C auf A.
Ist das, oder?
Chat, ist das Typ A?
Also das ist definitiv USB-C.
Und das hier ist
Typ A, glaube ich.
Übrigens, wir machen
gerade kein Dark Chrysal Grind.
Also heute stimmt nicht.
Aber wir machen vielleicht,
können wir heute Abend Dark Chrysal Grind?
Das hat ja vielen gefallen,
was mir gefallen hat.
Also, können wir...
Ich schmeiße mal kurz den Kram hier in die Ecke.
Kann man nicht einfach...
Wartet mal.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Können wir nicht...
Also gehen wir mal von aus, wir stecken das da vorne rein.
So, gehen wir mal von aus,
wir stecken das da vorne rein.
Hallo?
USB, come on.
Wir stecken das da...
Ne, hier rein kann ich es da nicht legen, da ist ja der Deckel.
Da ist ja der Deckel davor.
Das funktioniert ja nicht.
Ne, das klappt nicht.
Ich muss das irgendwie vorne
nebendran legen.
Vielleicht machen wir ein bisschen Velcro dran oder so
und pappen es an die Seite, oder?
Mal schauen.
Gut, das machen wir nachher.
Also das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht weiter mit beschäftigen.
SSD hier hin.
Schauen wir noch schnell mal in den anderen
Krempel rein.
Was ist das hier?
Gut, das muss ich nicht aufmachen.
Das ist ne M2.
Aber das Ding gucken wir uns mal an.
Das ist ja so ein Wechsel...
Ne, was heißt kein Wechselrahmen?
Das ist ja so ein USB zu M2.
Also ich werde beides mal anschließen,
weil mich einfach die Performance-Unterschiede
auch interessieren würden.
Ich muss den Scheiß nur mal kurz...
Alter, ist das kackeverpackt, Mann.
Mal öffnen.
Und den Server mal runterstellen.
Weil sonst sieht man nix.
So, Velcro ist echt praktisch.
Ja.
Ich hab mir auch mal so zwei Säckchen gekauft.
Mit diesen Velcro-Aufklebern,
die schon so zurechtgeschnitten sind.
Die sind äußerst praktisch.
So, machen wir das Teil mal auf.
Ich pfeffer das alles auf die Erde.
Oh, what the fuck?
Was ist denn hier alles drinne?
Thank you.
For traveling this icy box.
Weg.
Alles in die Ecke pfeffern.
So, was haben wir denn hier drinne?
Ah, guck mal.
Hier hätten wir ja zur Abwechslung...
Gut, dass ich das gekauft hab.
Wenn überhaupt kann man zumindest das USB-Kabel hierfür verwenden.
So, wie funzt das jetzt?
Moment, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Das muss ich mal kurz angucken.
Wie funzt das jetzt?
Da sind Schrauben.
Da ist der USB.
Kommt das...
Muss man das aufschrauben und die M2...
Wahrscheinlich kommt die M2 dann da rein.
Hat jetzt zwar nicht so direkt
was mit der Serverkiste zu tun, aber...
Ich mein...
Warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Riesen... Warum ist das eigentlich so ne mega fette
Verpackung für sowas kleines?
Checkt das jemand? Warum muss das so groß sein?
Warum muss man da so viel...
Dreck fabrizieren
für eine Mini
M2 Platine?
Wie funzt?
Chat, was meint ihr? Wo muss man aufmachen?
Auf der Seite?
Oder auf der Seite?
Ich hab das Handbuch schon weggeschmissen.
Ich lecke critical information.
Welche Seite ist
die richtige?
Wahrscheinlich beide, weil es sonst nicht slidet.
Boah, ist das ein räudiger
Schraubenzieher.
Boah, ist das... Das ist Müll.
Das fühlt sich echt an wie so ein
5 Cent China-Chinesen-Ding.
Ist es wahrscheinlich auch. Das fühlt sich nicht nur so an.
Boah.
Da schaffst du nicht mal
deine Hand draufzulassen.
Ah, okay. Man muss
beides abmachen, sonst... Was ist das?
Oh.
RIP.
Nein, nicht RIP.
Okay, das macht nen billigen
Eindruck, Leute.
Das macht nen billigen Eindruck, das Ding.
Guck mal, ich krieg's noch nicht mal mehr drauf.
Da, wo der USB...
What the fuck?
Ach so, so.
Na klar.
Machen wir mal auf.
Der ist von chinesischen für chinesische Kinderhände.
Der schraubt geherrscht.
Das wirkt echt so.
Also, du kannst damit eigentlich nix machen.
Boah.
Okay, das ist richtiger Pains-Champ von der Handhabung.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Und jetzt rein damit.
Gachi-Bass.
Äh, Leute, mir fehlt ne Schraube.
Ist die Schraube vielleicht bei der
SSD in der Packung drinne gewesen?
Die Packung, die ich gerade
quer durch den Raum geschmissen hab?
Könnte
das möglich sein?
SSD-only-Array mach ich
nicht. Die SSD ist
nur als Cache.
Die Schraube ist beim Mainboard dabei.
Ja gut, das Mainboard ist in dem
Falle das Ding. Okay, dann muss ich mal kurz
graben. Ich hab das quer durch den Raum
gepfeffert. Das liegt irgendwo.
Da ist es.
Screws.
Mhm.
Was auch immer
mir diese Teile...
Ah, das ist, wenn ich was verloren hab
oder so. Nice.
Die Dinger kann man ja nicht
falsch reinstecken, ne? Also, die
gehen ja nur in eine Richtung.
Was? Hey, Max, so oft wie du den...
Was? Keck, wait.
Wat?
Nehm einfach eine Schraube und feil sie
ein bisschen ab. Ach, Cache.
Natürlich nehm ich ein Cache.
Das ist zu high IQ
für mich, der Witz.
Das kapier ich nicht.
Ne, ne.
Ey, ich krieg mit diesem Ding... Ich raste.
Ich dreh gleich durch. Ohne Scheiß.
Ich dreh gleich durch.
Bis ich das da drinne hab, man.
Mon KS.
Wer hat sich dieses System ausgedacht, alter?
What the fuck?
So, okay.
Installed.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Man braucht doch dieses dumme Gehäuse gar nicht
zum Testen.
Ich mein, wozu brauch ich das Gehäuse,
wenn ich es einfach so reinstecken kann?
Also,
Kühlung. Ach, was?
Kühlung. Lull.
Auch keine Kühlung.
Bei mir hat das Ding auf dem Mainboard, wenn du es in
M2-Slot pappst, auch keine Kühlung.
Wozu Kühlung? Das Ding
steckst du normalerweise ohne jegliche Kühlung
aufs Mainboard.
Warum sollte das Kühlung brauchen?
Von dem Windzug auf dem Mainboard.
Ah, okay. Da ist...
Ja, das lass ich mir gefallen.
Okay, Chat.
Ihr habt mich überzeugt.
Ich sollte das besser in das
Gehäuse stecken. Ja, okay.
Wo ist denn jetzt vorne
und wo ist hinten gewesen? So glaub ich war das, ne?
Reingesteckt.
So.
Oh, nee. Please.
Diese Minischrauben,
Alter.
No, God!
No,
God, please, no!
Okay, wartet
mal drei... Ach du Scheiße.
Wartet mal drei Stunden, dann hab ich das
wieder drinne. Guck mal hier.
Seht ihr das?
Was ist das für eine Schraube, Mann?
Relax Critical Information.
Und wisst ihr was? Das Ding ist nicht mal
magnetisch hier.
Ach du große
Scheiße.
Okay.
Okay, ganz ruhig.
Einfach... Oh, Gott.
Come on, Bru.
Oh, nee.
Oh, nee. Okay.
Erster. Erster.
Erster ist drin.
Next.
Jetzt mal ganz im Ernst.
Wollen die da nicht normale Schrauben hin?
Und jetzt
sag nicht, es passt nicht. Da drin ist nur 90%
Luft.
Okay, okay.
Nice. Wir machen Progress. Wir machen Fortschritt.
Kosten minimieren, weil China Chinesen
kramen. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich.
So, guck mal.
Gleich haben wir es. Noch zwei Schrauben.
Dann geht's
los. Erste Schraube.
Dann schalten wir nämlich
die Kiste an und hauen
Unraid drauf.
Also vorher schrauben wir die
Kiste zu und hauen dann Unraid drauf.
Dann gucken wir
uns auch gleich schon mal hier den Stromverbrauch
an. Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Gut.
Finished.
Ich lass das mal hier liegen.
Ja, kommt alles hier mal
auf den Schreibtisch.
Alles klar. Hier haben wir die USB-Sticks.
Dann schrauben wir jetzt mal
zu.
Dann schrauben wir jetzt mal zu.
Lass mal überlegen. Habe ich irgendwas
vergessen? Chat.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht Critical Information lecken.
Habe ich irgendwas vergessen,
was ich machen muss, solange es noch auf ist?
Festplatten rein.
Ja, Festplatten rein muss ich machen.
Aber Festplatten rein habe ich ja schon.
Ich will es ja nur testen
im Endeffekt.
Also am Ende kommen dann irgendwie 18T
Platten oder so. Mal gucken.
Oder eine 18T Parity
und irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Mal schauen.
Ich mache es erst mal ohne an.
Leute, ich lasse es offen.
Ich mache ohne an, weil ich den Stromverbrauch
sehen will.
Ich will den Stromverbrauch sehen
ohne Platte, ohne
SSD, ohne alles.
Aber mit USB-Stick gebootet.
Weil oftmals, wenn die Dinger im Bios
sind, beziehungsweise
Self-Test machen, brauchen die mehr Strom.
Als wenn die ins Betriebssystem
gebootet sind. Deswegen
machen wir uns mal
einen Unraid
USB-Stick.
Würde ich sagen.
Na, wenn der offen ist, ist es nicht
schlimm.
Wir machen uns einen Unraid
USB-Stick. Gibt es diesen
Unraid
Unraid Download. Gibt es diesen
Unraid USB
Key-Ersteller
auch für Linux?
Wieso steckst du nicht
die MX500 rein, weil es SATA ist?
Und SATA ist langsamer als 10 Gigabit
SSD. Äh, als 10 Gigabit
USB.
Also die USB-SSD ist wahrscheinlich schneller.
Okay, den USB-Creator
gibt es noch für Windows.
Download Unraid.
Unraid. Kannst du die ISO?
Ich würde die ISO flashen, aber es
gibt kein ISO.
Unraid ist das einzige, was irgendwie der Meinung ist.
ISO? Was? Das ist zu advanced.
ISO gibt es nicht.
Okay. Also,
wir nehmen jetzt den hier.
Moment, ich muss euch den...
Ah, die Musik dazu, die passt ja wieder gut.
Doch, es gibt
kein ISO. Kein offizielles ISO.
Wir nehmen erstmal den SanDisk.
Muss ich mal aufmachen.
Intrusion detects...
Ah, ihr meint, der
detectet, ob das offen ist. Und wenn es offen ist,
blasen die Lüfter mehr, oder was?
Das könnte tatsächlich sein,
ja. Alter, wir hatten
diese USB-Sticks wieder verpackt. Geht wieder
nicht auf.
Ich nehme bei, ist schon der Wahnsinne.
So.
Da ist er. USB-Stick am Start.
Ähm...
Also.
USB-Creator.
Oh Mist, welches Kabel kann ich denn jetzt überhaupt
rausziehen, um hier USB zu createn? Ich glaube,
das hier ist für
die Elgato-Karte. Die brauchen wir nicht.
Jawoll.
Übrigens, guck mal, dieser USB-Stick ist richtig
pfeifert.
Guck mal, passt mal auf. Ich dachte erst,
als ich die Packung aufgemacht habe,
das ist ein USB-C
USB-Stick. Aber,
jetzt passt mal auf,
es ist
Dual-Wield.
Und hier ist der USB 3.1.
Ich will nicht den höchstmöglichen Stromverbrauch
messen. Ich möchte den EIDL-Stromverbrauch
messen.
Ist der nicht zu groß? Da steht
was von 32G.
Ernsthaft? Das ist wirklich so?
Das habe ich im Vorfeld schon gelesen, im Forum.
So.
So, nach dem Öffnen.
Also dein USB-Stick muss über eine
gültige GUID verfügen.
Macht er wahrscheinlich mindestens ein
höchstens 32G?
Was?
Ihr wollt mir doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen,
dass das Ding nicht funktioniert mit einem größeren USB-Stick.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Warum?
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Warum sollte das so sein?
Ich meine, hat er das jetzt in die...
Nein, nein. Connect to Host.
USB-Drive.
SanDisk. Memory Zone
Installer. Ja, ganz
bestimmt. Ganz bestimmt SanDisk.
Okay.
Also, wenn das jetzt wirklich nicht funktioniert,
dann muss ich echt, muss ich echt
eine Runde kek-kek-dabbeln.
Der erkennt den wirklich nicht.
Wie schlecht kann man eigentlich sein?
Immer, dass man immer extra Wurst machen muss,
Weil die Hersteller irgendeinen Kack machen,
der komplett weltfremd ist.
Hat hier wer Proxmox mit Full-Disk-Encryption laufen?
Ne.
Aber wir haben schon mal Full-Disk-Encryption von Hand gemacht
zum SSH entlocken.
Also, Unraid,
USB-Stick, Larger,
32 GB,
Larger,
Does size matter, GachiBuzz?
No.
64 GB.
Unraid-Image
ist 450 MB.
Ja, warum?
Warum gehen nur...
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn!
Warum sollte der maximal 32 GB erlauben?
Hast du dein USB-Stick eine gültige GUI?
Bestimmt, warum soll er das nicht haben?
Ernsthaft?
Ich meine, ich hab hier ja noch den...
Wo hab ich den denn?
Ich hab noch diesen ganz alten USB 2.16 G,
aber den wollte ich dafür jetzt eigentlich gar nicht verwenden.
Die Beschränkung kommt nur vom Unraid-Tool.
Nimm ein anderes und fertig.
Ja.
Anderes was?
Ach, der brauchenden 32 GB
Ja, dem können wir Abhilfe schaffen.
Dem können wir Abhilfe schaffen.
Das ist kein Problem.
Guck mal, der hat ein FAT32
Also scheint irgendwie auch mehr zu gehen.
Ja, aber dem können wir echt Abhilfe schaffen.
Das ist kein Problem.
Da muss ich bloß aufpassen.
Das ist meine Linux-Festplatte, das ist der USB-Stick.
Ähm...
Delete
New
FAT32
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Wollte ich das schon immer mal haben.
Äh, save.
Aber ich lese mal durch, ob es noch ein paar andere Sachen gibt.
Best USB... USB-Kompatible...
64G. Nee, geht nicht.
Why waste...
Ich hasse solche Antworten.
Der Typ fragt, wird das funktionieren?
Why waste storage?
Weil ein fucking
64G-Stick 1 Cent
mehr kostet als ein 32G-Stick
und im Zweifelsfall wegen
Leveling sogar noch länger hält.
Was eine
bescheuerte Antwort. Ich hasse solche...
Das ist wie das Micro-Controller-Forum.
Da muss es doch... Okay, okay.
Wir machen was anderes.
Create USB manual.
Manually.
Aha, Legacy. Guck mal da.
Legacy.
Preparing USB.
Aha, okay.
Es gibt keine ISO.
Manual Install
Method. Aha.
Aha.
Okay. Plug USB
device into bla bla bla.
Set volume label to unrate
all uppercase.
Man soll das ZIP runterladen.
Content extracten.
Also im Prinzip soll man
das ZIP auf den USB-Stick extracten.
Und wenn man UEFI-Boot machen will,
was wir btw. machen wollen,
soll man das Directory umbenennen
von EFI-
zu EFI und dann
make bootable script
ausführen.
Okay.
Note this method only works
for devices 32 GB
and smaller. Das macht keinen Sinn.
Das liegt bestimmt nur an der
Partition, die maximal 32 GB
sein darf.
Das machen wir jetzt trotzdem.
Das funktioniert schon.
So.
Ich muss es mal kurz
verkleinern hier oben.
Also was soll ich
runterladen? Das ZIP.
Das da. Okay.
Save.
So.
Und jetzt?
Okay. Also ich soll das Ding, dann kann ich das
gleich schon mal rückgängig machen, was ich hier gemacht habe.
Das stimmt nämlich nicht.
Ich muss die FAT32 Partition anlegen,
die
unrate heißt.
So. Das Ganze ist, was weiß ich,
21 GB groß. Perfekt.
Genauso groß muss es sein.
So. Haben wir ein USB-Stick angelegt
mit dem Label unrate.
Oh, quit. Mehr müssen wir nicht machen.
Und jetzt
muss ich einfach das ZIP extracten, oder?
Ich glaube, das war's. sudo –i
mount
devsdb1
nach mnt
mnt
So. Kopieren wir jetzt mal nach
von home max
downloads unrate
das Ding dahin.
Und sagen unzip
unrate
unrate server
Fertig. Easy.
So. Unrate. Löschen wir wieder das ZIP.
Fertig.
Oh. Wenn das alles ist.
Obbei, nee, da kommt was.
You have renamed
zu efi, anders, äh, efi
äh, minus zu efi. Okay.
mv efi minus
efi minus
zu efi
efi,
okay, passt.
Und jetzt
run make
bootable script
äh
unmount usb
Ah, das muss ich
runterkopieren, oder was?
Also quasi, äh,
mnt
make
bootable linux
okay, das
In das Script guck ich mal rein,
bevor ich, bevor ich das ausführe.
So, unmount mnt
stop
Warum? Warum?
Das Script vom Stick
ausführen. Nee, ich kann das Script nicht vom Stick
ausführen, weil die sagen, ich soll es unmounten.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Copy make bootable file to
hard drive. Die meinen, man soll
das runterkopieren vom USB-Stick, weil danach
muss ich den USB-Stick unmounten.
So, wir gucken mal kurz,
was das Script macht.
So, nichts.
Ach, guck mal!
Der guckt einfach, ob unrate als
Label gesetzt ist. Deswegen musste man beim
Partition, äh, beim, beim
FAT32 musste man als Label
unrate setzen. Das ist, dass er den USB-Stick findet.
Und was macht
er danach? Mountet sich das Ganze
nochmal
und dann
kopiert er irgendwelche
Dinger um?
Okay. Sieht nicht, sieht nicht gefährlich
aus. Können wir ausführen.
Was? Wie soll ich's
ausführen mit Bash? Warum, warum?
Egal, ich hinterfrag das nicht.
So, make bootable.
The following
device appears to be the
unrate USB flash
drive.
Permit UEFI boot. Yes.
Okay.
Unrate OS
flash drive is now bootable
and may be ejected.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Disconnect.
Wie sieht das Ding jetzt
unter Windows aus, wenn man sich's anguckt?
Ja, da ist der ganze Mist drauf.
Probier mal aus. Probier mal aus.
Warum nicht? Okay.
USB-Stick.
Plop.
Äh.
Elgato.
Rein.
Okay.
Oh, das ist ganz schön.
Warum ist denn der USB-Stick warm geworden?
Ich mein, der sollte doch nicht, der USB-Stick sollte doch nicht
wirklich warm werden von, äh,
ich kopiere mal kurz ein paar MB drauf.
Was ist denn das?
Max liest Chat.
Da steht, er hat mcopy not found. Oh.
Was ist mcopy?
Stand, stand das eben? Dass er irgendwas nicht
gefunden hat?
Oh.
mcopy command not found.
Info ins, also hier nach.
Hier nach.
Moment, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, was
Was ist, was soll, hab ich noch nie gehört.
Hä?
Wo kommt, wo kommt das überhaupt her?
Wo kommt,
wo kommt denn diese Meldung überhaupt her?
Aus dem
zweiten Skript?
Ach hier, cp sys linux
tmp unrate.
Und was ist dollar source?
Was ist source?
Mount grab?
Ah, vom USB-Stick.
Ach, scheiß drauf, das wird schon funktionieren.
Wenn nicht, wenn nicht, machen wir das einfach neu.
Dann machen wir es mit dem
16G und dem offiziellen, wenn das nicht geht.
Okay.
Dann
stecken wir den USB-Stick doch mal
rein.
Guckt mal, hier ist ein USB 2,
interner USB 2 Stecker zum
booten.
Ich finde, das ist eine wirklich gut durchdachte Angelegenheit
hier mit dem internen USB 2.
Das gefällt mir, das hat was.
Ich habe einen alten 16G Stick,
ja, aber den will ich eigentlich nicht verwenden, der ist irgendwie
Canon, 12 Jahre alt oder so.
Okay, gut.
Alles
klar.
So, dann schließen wir mal an.
HDMI Kabel, komm her.
HDMI, wie die
coolen Leute sagen.
Kiste, das ist ein HP
Microserver Gen 10+,
wie es im Titel steht.
Jupp.
Äh.
Oh, shit, das war ja ein Display-Port, Leute.
Ich habe es ganz vergessen.
Das war ja ein Display-Port.
Ähm.
Äh.
Wie kriege ich, ich kann kein VGA
nehmen, weil
ich will euch das ja zeigen
mit der Capture-Karte. Die Capture-Karte
hat nur, ich habe
irgendwo einen
HDMI auf
Display-Port.
Wartet mal kurz. Boah, das finde
ich doch jetzt nicht.
Hier hängt was hinter meinem Schreibtisch.
Da ist ein Display-Port
dran.
Reicht das auf der anderen Seite ja ein
USB?
Ach, wie kriege ich ein
Warum machen die da eigentlich ein Display-Port
dran?
Wo geht denn das Kabel hier hin?
Dann schreib dich
gucken, wo das Kabel ist.
Was?
Was eine Kacke, Mann.
Warum ist da kein
HDMI-Port?
So, also das ist ein Display-Port-Kabel.
Kein USB, kein ähm
HDMI auf Display-Port.
Ha.
Ach, weil HDMI
Lizenzkosten kostet. Ah, das ist eine gute,
das kann sein, ja.
Leute, wie kriege ich denn das angeschlossen?
Ich habe nur ein HDMI-Kabel hier.
Ich weiß, ich habe irgendwo
mit Sicherheit
aber ich weiß nicht
wo
ein Display-Port auf HDMI.
Ich muss mal
kurz suchen, ob ich da irgendwas finde.
Ich guck jetzt mal
auf dem Schreibtisch. Was haben wir denn hier?
B
A
Fuck, Champ.
Bam.
Wie ich es einfach gefunden habe direkt.
Einfach direkt
gesercht und gefeindet.
So.
HDMI.
HDMI, komm her.
Nicht hängen bleiben jetzt.
Bam.
Ok. Äh, Sekunde,
Leute, ich muss mal kurz das Mikrofon nochmal abziehen,
weil ich muss meine Elgato-Karte hinter dem Schreibtisch,
also hinter dem Stuhl irgendwie lang...
Schauen wir mal. Low-Profile-Karte.
Grafikkarte in den PCI-Slot.
Nope, der ist voll mit einer 10-Gigabit-Karte.
Also, ich habe alles angeschlossen.
Bin mal gespannt.
Game Capture HD.
Was die so sagt.
Stromkabel.
Also, die sollte
die Elgato-Karte wenigstens erkennen.
So.
Netzteil.
Netzteil habe ich auch.
One moment.
No signal.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist richtig.
Da war noch nichts dran. Ok.
So, ich schließe mal das Netzteil an.
Ich lasse das Ding jetzt auf. Scheiß drauf.
Ich schließe jetzt das Netzteil an
und dann gucken wir mal.
Hier, Strom.
Strom kommt da rein,
vermute ich mal, hier.
Guck mal da. Da ist schon...
Ja, passt.
Ok. So, erzählen wir erstmal,
wie viel es beim Booten verbraucht. Beim Booten
verbraucht er wahrscheinlich unnötig
viel Strom.
Aber schauen wir mal.
Bumm.
11 Watt, 8,3.
Bootet er jetzt?
Chat?
Ne, der bootet nicht.
Da ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur das Board angegangen jetzt.
Einmal rumdrehen das Ganze.
Und Power Button.
Ach, guck mal hier, ohne leuchtet es jetzt auch.
Guck mal, Poggas.
Leucht... Der Leuchtchamp.
Ah, es geht an.
Es geht an.
37 Watt.
Boah.
Ok, das ist aber... Die Dinger brauchen beim Anlaufen immer viel.
Achso.
Zack.
Äh... No Output?
Warum kein Output? No Signal?
Why?
Warum kein Signal?
An ist er.
Bläst volle Pulle.
Ich mach das nochmal neu auf.
Weil VGA erst...
Quatsch.
Wieso kann VGA genutzt werden, wenn zwei Anschlüsse dafür da sind?
Protecting Signal.
Ist das Problem?
Ist das HDMI Kabel kaputt?
Der erkennt noch nicht mal, dass es ein- und ausgestöpselt wird.
Das ist merkwürdig.
Ah, warte mal, habe ich es falsch?
Leute, ich habe es bestimmt falsch rum an der Elgato dran.
Passt auf, ich habe es falsch rum an der 100 Pro.
Ich habe es am Output dran, anstatt am Input.
Keck wait.
Jetzt habe ich es richtig dran.
Ich hatte das Zeug am Output richtig hängen geblieben.
Okay, Game Capture.
Wow, der bläst gerade volle Pulle.
Jetzt ist er leiser geworden.
Postchip?
Leute, ich glaube, der hat gebootet.
Ich glaube, der hat gebootet.
Ich guck mal kurz in meinen Router.
Aber ich würde ja schon gerne was sehen.
IP Server DHCP
Keine Ahnung, da hätte ich jetzt mal draufgucken müssen.
Das müsste 2.
Ich weiß nicht, was der für eine IP jetzt bekommen hat.
Falls der gebootet hat.
Warum geht diese Kacke jetzt?
Warum ist das immer so ein Rotz?
Warum habe ich diesen Kack überhaupt, wenn es nie funktioniert?
Nee, Dynamic habe ich.
Nee, der hat nicht gebootet.
Doch, der hat gebootet.
Moment.
Was ist das hier?
Ach nee, das ist mein Desktop.
Nee, der hat nicht gebootet.
Okay, ähm.
Du hast eine IP-KVM.
Ja, irgendwo, keine Ahnung.
Nee, die Mac vom Server habe ich nicht.
Aber ich sehe das ja anhand des Hausnamens, welches das ist.
Und welches Netz das ist, das es nicht gezogen hat.
Habe ich vielleicht das Elgato Zeug hier drin irgendwie eingerichtet, so das es nicht funktioniert?
Nee.
Der hat kein Management Interface.
So.
Also, vielleicht ist das HDMI Kabel kaputt.
Möglich.
Ach so, Leute ich habe gar kein Netzwerkkabel drinne, fällt mir ein.
Da kann sich gar keine IP ziehen.
Aber ich will auch gar nicht, dass da sich eine IP zieht.
Ich will, dass ich den Output sehe von dem Teil.
Okay, Leute, wir schalten nochmal aus.
Übrigens, jetzt sind wir eitel bei 20 Watt, was durchaus okay aussieht.
Ich schalte nochmal aus.
Ich schalte nochmal komplett aus.
Vielleicht ist das HDMI-Kabel kaputt.
Ich hatte mit diesem Kabel in Verbindung mit der Elgato schon mal Probleme.
Aber ich finde auf die Schnelle, glaube ich, jetzt kein anderes HDMI-Kabel.
So, er ist aus.
Er ist aus.
Okay.
Machen wir nochmal an.
Ah, ich wollte einen USB-Stick rausziehen vorher.
Der soll ja gar nicht booten, richtig?
Hast du bei Twitter mitbekommen, NFT-Scams bei Monats-Monte-Gewinnspiel?
Ach, keine Ahnung, was mit dem Kerl los ist.
Ich verstehe, ganz ehrlich, ich checke es ja eh gar nicht, warum alle so auf NFTs abgehen.
Das ist mir komplett schleierhaft.
Manche Display-Ports unterstützen nur Ausgabe auf Display.
Das wäre ziemlich hängen geblieben, wenn bei einem Display-Port auf HDMI-Adapter kein HDMI unterstützt werden würde, oder?
Leute, ich brauche ein anderes HDMI-Kabel.
Ich muss mal kurz suchen.
Ich habe sau viele, ich weiß nur nicht wo.
Das sieht ein bisschen nach Hand aus.
Ich wusste es nur in den Knoten.
Amazon Basic, aber...
Ach, scheiße.
Guckt mal.
Das ist ein...
Ist ja noch schlechter.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist denn das überhaupt?
Was ist das hier, Chat?
Chat, sag mir, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Was ist das überhaupt?
HDMI?
Mini-HDMI oder sowas?
So kack, warum habe ich denn sowas überhaupt?
Wer braucht denn sowas?
Das ist ein useless Ding.
Ah, das habe ich, glaube ich, für einen Raspberry Pi mal gehabt.
Das kann schon sein.
Ich brauche einen HDMI-Kabel.
Ich brauche einen HDMI-Kabel, Leute.
Ich suche weiter.
HDMI-Kabel.
USB-Verlängerung habe ich in Amazon Basic.
Definitiv.
Ich wusste doch irgendwo, dass ich das habe.
Warte, für wie...
Jetzt mal, blöde Frage.
Für wie...
Für wie wahrscheinlich haltet ihr es, dass das HDMI-Kabel wirklich das Problem ist?
100%.
Quatsch.
Das HDMI-Kabel, das ist bestimmt irgendwas anderes.
Egal, ich suche mal weiter.
Chat, ich habe eins.
Ich habe eins.
Amazon Basic, glaube ich.
Amazon Basic.
Aber mir egal, ob es das funktioniert.
Amazon Basic funzt in der Regel.
Die sind so basiert.
Based HDMI-Kabel.
Okay, tauschen wir aus und gucken dann, ob es funktioniert.
HDMI.
Ich müsste es eigentlich durchschleifen und an einem Monitor gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Macht ihr Elgato nicht normalerweise?
Ich stöpsel...
Leute, ich stöpsel...
Ich stöpsel die nochmal ab.
Die macht nämlich normalerweise so komische Lichter.
One moment, please.
Ach, das funktioniert jetzt für uns nicht.
Ja, ja, no input.
Okay, jetzt schalte ich wieder ein.
Ne, Leute, das funktioniert nicht.
An active dongle must be used or passive dongles will not allow video to be displayed.
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Mann, ich will...
Ich will den Monitor daran anschließen, Alter.
Kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein, oder?
Das kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein, dass ich...
Irgendwie ein Spezial...
Okay, ist das Ding aktiv?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, sonst wird es nicht funktionieren.
Das ist ein HDMI.
Ja, man weiß es nicht.
Das ist bestimmt irgendein passives Kabel.
Ja, guckt mal.
Okay, wie...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich da...
Ich hab keinen VGA-Anschluss.
Wozu eigentlich?
Für das eine Mal wurde uns kurz das...
Na, ich will ins BIOS gucken.
Ich will zum Beispiel im BIOS Virtualisierungskram einschalten und sowas.
Ich muss doch ins BIOS kommen von meiner Kiste.
Ist doch jetzt keine Option, nicht ins BIOS zu kommen, weil ich mich nicht anstöpseln kann.
Ich hab noch kein VGA-Kabel mehr.
Woher soll ich denn VGA-Kabel haben?
VGA-Kabel braucht man seit...
Nein, das hat theoretisch die Option auf dem Management-Port, aber ich hab keinen Management-Port.
Ich hab tatsächlich ein IP-KVM.
Irgendwo, Leute.
Irgendwo hab ich ein IP-KVM.
Aber wirklich irgendwo mit VGA.
Ich weiß nicht, wo der ist.
Wirklich nicht.
Ich lecke Critical Cables.
Ja, ich seh's.
Also ohne Scheiß, das IP-KVM-Ding hab ich seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr gesehen oder so.
Keine Ahnung, wo das ist.
Wirklich absolut kein Schimmer.
Ha.
Wie?
Wie komm ich da jetzt ran?
Hab ich irgendwo OGA?
Nee, ich hab kein VGA mehr.
Geh auch bestimmt nicht zu meinem Nachbarn und frag, hast du ein paar VGA-Kabel?
Zumal ich auch was habe, um das anschließen zu müssen.
Also, okay.
Was gehen würde ist, ich schließe einfach mein Display an, dann seht ihr es nicht.
Das würde aber...
Das will ich jetzt nicht on-stream machen.
Dann kann ich...
Weil wenn ihr nix seht, ist langweilig.
Also, Venture, müsst ihr das sehen?
Oder ich kann's sein lassen?
Ähm...
Kann ich auf Bildschirm richten?
Ich überleg gerade...
Wo ist das?
Wo ist das IP-KVM?
Ich schau mal kurz in meine Kisten, ob ich's zufälligerweise finde auf den ersten Blick.
Leute!
Ich hab meine Playstation Vita gefunden!
Leute, ich liebe meine Ordnung.
Ich hab's gefunden.
Meine Ordnung ist nicht vorhanden.
Aber ich weiß grob, wo was liegt.
So ungefähr.
So.
Ich zeig's euch mal.
Ich zeig...
Ich zeig euch mal das Ding.
Oh, oh, oh, fuck.
Jetzt hab ich...
Ah!
Mein Headset-Zeug runtergeschmissen.
Alter.
Painz Champ.
So.
Ich hab's gefunden.
Ich zeig's euch.
Hier ist es.
Guck mal.
Hier ist es. Guck mal.
Äh...
Da.
Spider.
Und es hat nen VGA.
Und es hat...
Äh...
Zweimal USB.
Nice.
Dann schließen wir das doch mal an.
Da brauch ich nur ne Netzwerkkabel.
Äh...
Da muss ich den Switch...
Muss ich den Switch anschalten hier hinten.
Weil hier hinten ist der 10G-Switch.
Und hier ist ein Kabel.
Okay.
Also.
VGA dran.
Hock.
Champ.
Äh...
USB dran.
Und...
Netzwerk dran.
Sollte funktionieren.
Und jetzt gucken, was das Ding für ne IP bekommen hat.
Außer Atem von Suchen.
Da seht ihr mal, was ich für euch mache, Chat.
Das ist jetzt mal mindestens 5 Prime-Subscriptions wert.
Ich muss mir das Essen kaufen, um die Kalorien wieder aufzufüllen.
So.
Leases.
Da.
Hier.
Das ist die IP von dem Teil.
Oder auch nicht.
Das sollte eigentlich die IP von dem Ding sein.
So.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich kann grad nicht gucken.
Wer war's?
Wem hab ich den Sub zu verdanken?
Oh.
Nice.
Danke, danke, Leute.
KalashX21.
Fünf Stück.
Danke, danke.
Für das Schatten-Vibe.
Für den, äh, Wasser-Esser.
Für itsmurxer.
Maxxi.
Und Velox.
Der Rest hat gedodged.
Hast du auf dem Spider schon die neueste Firmware?
Nein.
Wie macht man dann Firmware-Update?
Äh.
Wolle.
Auch zwei Subscriptions für Spider-Man.
Ja.
Und zwei Subscriptions für Scarf und Exclusive.
Pok pok.
Danke, danke, Leute.
Ich hab.
Ach, guck mal da.
Oh, fuck.
Username, Passwort.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Usen...
Ah.
She baited.
You got she baited.
Got she baited.
Admin, Admin bestimmt, ja.
Bestimmt Admin, Admin.
Na, wublos at gmx ist es eher nicht.
Admin, Admin.
Nope.
Na, wublos at gmx ist es eher nicht.
Admin, Admin.
Nope.
Es ist nicht.
Admin, Admin.
Landronics Spider.
Default Password.
Pass.
The defacto default username is just admin.
Default password is pass.
Ich find's immer wieder erstaunlich, wie gut, dass der Chat hinbekommt...
Fuck, das geht nicht.
Wie gut, dass der Chat hinbekommt, so zu tun, als wüsste er, wovon er spricht.
Hab aber keine Ahnung.
Fuck.
Okay, so wie ich mich kenne
Admin, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Nein, fuck
Sys, Admin
Ich hab das richtig geschrieben
Und dann
Pass
Shit
Wie resettet man das?
Heute ist wieder alles
gegen uns, alter Leute
2007 bis 2010
Sys, Admin
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Ah
Der Chat
Der Hackerman-Scherz
Easy as fuck
Easy as
Easy
Get rekt
Easy as fuck
Okay, wunderbar
Click to open KVM-Console
I
Java
Nein, nicht schon wieder
Nicht schon wieder
MonkaCross
Weg, weiche Teufel
Teufel, geh weg
Kann man das Update
Maintenance-Firmware-Update
Irgendeiner hat auch gesagt
Es gibt
Es gibt Firmware-Updates dafür
Landtronics
Spider
Firmware
Für meinen gibt es bestimmt nichts mehr
Das ist so alt
Product
Landtronics
SLS
Ach guck mal, der Chat weiß Bescheid
Wie hast du das jetzt gefunden?
SLS
Ne
Ach hier
Das ist bestimmt nicht das Ding, oder?
Ich mein, meins ist von 2007
Das ist bestimmt out of life, was ich hier hab
Oder meint ihr das?
Meint ihr das geht?
Woher weiß ich denn für was es ist?
Du hast das gleich, okay
Und das hat jetzt HTML5 mit dem Update hier
Right click, save as
Save as, alles klar
Was davon brauch ich denn überhaupt?
Äh
Was davon ist jetzt das Richtige?
Firmware
Also ich hab die Auswahl zwischen
Firmware und Firmware
Geil
Sehr aussagekräftig
Wahrscheinlich brauch ich das obere
Ja ich hab den Hinweis gelesen, ich weiß aber nicht was die mir damit sagen wollen
Spider
Ach so
Moment, ich muss beides flashen, oder was?
Ich muss erst die alte flashen
Und dann die neue?
Weil meine Firmware ist, Firmware Version
3.1
Ne
Ich hab schon eine neu genüge
Neu genüge Firmware
Okay
Update Firmware
Browse, Downloads
Die da
Upload
Schauen wir mal
Ach so, muss man bestimmt entzippen, jaja
Zip
Monka Zip
Unzip
Spider
Inflating
Spider Bin
Kennt ihr noch Spider Ants aus
Borderlands?
Spider Ants
Ne, das ist das falsche
Moment, ich hab das falsche
Monka S, das ist bestimmt nicht was ich da hab
Doch, ich hab das Richtige
Entpackt, aber
Okay
Gnome Anzeige
Die Bin ist kleiner als die Zip
Tja, effektiv gezippt würde ich sagen
Ahem
Weiß
Alter, jetzt mal ganz im Ernst
Hut ab, ich habe keine Ahnung
Wer genau Landtronics ist
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, Hut ab
Dass die für eine Hardware
Von 2007
Firmware Update
Rausbringen
Jetzt mal ernsthaft Chat
Also dafür können wir eine Runde
Pogchampion mal im Chat
Oder irgendwas, was auch immer
Aber das ist schon ziemlich gut, oder?
Ich kann nicht zugeben
Hyper Clap
Also ich finde das ist gut
Okay, take several minutes
Auf geht's
Dann take'em mal several minutes
Und update'e
Hat wer eine Empfehlung
Für eine bezahlbare IP-Karform
Ja, dieses Ding was ich da hab
Das ist gut, das kostet bei Ebay 50 Euro
Landtronics
SLS
Oh
50 Euro
40 Euro Versand
Habt ihr den Arsch offen, oder was?
Also ich hab das für 50, 60 Euro
Damals gekauft
Das war wohl ein guter Deal
Gibt es nicht
Für den Pi ein fertiges Image
Für LAN-KVM, doch
Aber das komplizierte ist ja nicht ein Pi-Image
Zu flashen, sondern du brauchst ja die ganze Hardware
Dafür
Schreibt den mal
Das ist ne gute Idee
Das mach ich
Landtronics
Okay Chat, was schreiben wir denen
Bin ich hier bei Twitter eingeloggt
Ja
Also was schreiben wir denen
Wir schreiben denen
Add
Landtronics
Huge
Props
Oder was schreiben wir denen
Ähm
Erstmal schauen ob das Firmware Update geht, ja
Device will reboot in a few seconds
Login Page
Okay wir schreiben
Wir schreiben denen mal was, okay, okay
Huge Poggers
Ne
Ich glaub man sagt da Huge Props
Ich weiß gar nicht, was heißt das auf Deutsch direkt übersetzt
So das gebührt Respekt
Oder irgendwie sowas heißt das
Mad Respect
For
Up
For offering
New Firmware
Device from
Wir machen ihnen jetzt noch ein Screenshot rein
Dann freuen die sich
Oh ich glaub die Firmware hat's
Hat's gebrickt
Hat's die Firmware gebrickt, Leute
Ne, ne, es pinkt noch, okay
Das braucht
Das braucht einfach nur lange
Wow, was ist das
Ah, wie geht das weg
Okay
Saved, Saved
Saved
Ich glaub das bootet einfach nur 3 Stunden
Weil da ist es ja
Das hat sich auch vor 8 Minuten zuletzt
Das hat sich vor 8 Minuten zuletzt die IP gezogen
Also
Ich hab da so meine Zweifel, dass das schon gebootet ist
Ob das nen Bug hat und nicht richtig bootet
Ne andere IPs
Haben wir auch nicht
Ah da sind wir, hey
Also sysadmin
sysadmin123456
So und das kann jetzt angeblich
HTML5
Nein das ist
Das ist noch Java
Äh
Kann man das umstellen auf HTML5
Jetzt irgendwie, Services
Maintenance
Sieht wie Fake Update aus
Naja
Das ist die aktuellste Version
Interfaces KVM
Interfaces
SSHX
Man kann sich da
Ernsthaft per SSH
Video vielleicht
Ne
KVM Console
Settings
HTML5 alter nice
PogChamp
HTML5
Guckt es euch mal an
Wahnsinn
Ok das
Schreiben wir den jetzt mal
Ähm Maintenance
Äh Firmaversion
Aber hier schneiden wir mit Paint aus
Pass auf Mac
Und IP liegt öffentlich auf Twitter
OMG
Mit dem WebVNC ist er, ich glaub das ist der einzige
Wisst ihr was
Wir triggern jetzt noch
Pass mal auf, wir triggern noch die Leute auf Twitter
Es ist vollkommen, by the way
Nur so, es ist vollkommen egal
Dass ähm
Dass man das sieht, was willst du damit
Anfangen, mit ner Mac von nem
Dings das bei mir im internen Netz hängt
Mit ner Board ID und IP
Wir triggern die Leute noch bei
Bei Twitter, ich mach das jetzt unkenntlich
Aber so, dass man das noch erkennt
Wobei eigentlich
Ist zu viel Arbeit oder
Weiß gar nicht ob das in Paint geht
Ich wollte eigentlich in Paint
Sowas hier machen irgendwie
Ich wollte es quasi so halb durchsichtig machen
Dass die Leute mir dann antworten
Aber Max, aber Max, man sieht doch noch alles
Egal ich poste
Poste das jetzt
For Girls
Muss dann auch hinten dran
Vielleicht sollte ich auch noch unten das mit
Ich kopie, ich kopie jetzt
Waren das, hä
So
Ich hab's ihnen, ich hab's ihnen geschrieben
Wenn ihr wollt
Könnt ihr das mal liken
Dann sehen sie das vielleicht
Und wenn sie es sehen, mach ich ein Sponsoring
Mit denen
So, äh hier, da
Hab ich's gepostet
IP League, OMG
Okay, okay, nice
Okay, jetzt machen wir mal mit der eigentlichen Geschichte weiter
Also wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Da, Spider
Also, hier haben wir den Output
Und jetzt kann ich sogar booten
Und, und ins Bios gehen
Und sowas
Acreege, richtig Acreege
Massive Acreege hier
So, machen wir aus, jetzt ist er aus
Sollte sich zumindest ausgeschaltet haben
Eigentlich
Schau mal an
Sollte das da hoffentlich was anzeigen
Gleich
Äh
Was anderes als booting, weil ich hab ihn restartet
Ah
Okay, das ist dumm
Das Ding restartet sich, weil es am USB
Angeschlossen ist
Painz Champ, wenn ich den Rechner ausschalte
Ist das Ding aus
Das dürfen wir nicht machen
Ey, das muss ich woanders anschließen, Leute
Keck wait, ja
Richtig, richtig keck wait
Das USB muss ich anderweitig anschließen
Das USB muss an die Steckdose
Sonst wird
Oh fuck, jetzt ist hier ganz schön das
Rumgefuddel
Ich brauch ne USB Verlängerung
Das ist natürlich ziemlich dumm
Aber trotzdem
Huge, huge props
Huge massive props
Alter
USB Verlängerung, komm her
Äh, was ist mein Telefon
Das da?
Ah
Tatsächlich
Mist
Entknoten
Dass ich's verlängern kann
Okay, es ist an
Jetzt müssen wir warten, bis es gebootet ist
Genau, da sind zweimal USB dran
Einer ist Power, einer ist Tastatur
Jetzt müssen wir warten, bis es gebootet ist
Das dauert wieder drei Stunden
Also eins muss ich jetzt sagen
Bootgeschwindigkeit
Ist wirklich nicht der Wahnsinn von dem Teil
Aber man
Ohne Scheiß, ich find das wirklich gut, dass es da ist
Das die für ein Produkt von
2007-2022
Firmware Updates
Die Leute auf Twitter wieder
Ich glaube
Die denken auch, was für ein komischer Typ
Hat er an uns hier auf Twitter bitteschön geschrieben
So, und das erste
Was die sehen ist das da
Nice
Das ist doch nicht mal das richtige Coggers
Das ist irgendwie ein kaputtes Coggers
Das ist Coggerslide oder sowas
Das Netzwerkkabel fehlt
Das weiß ich, dass das fehlt
Da sind wir wieder
sysadmin123456
Super Coggers Passwort
KVM Konsole
Haha
Nice
Ok, Bios
Äh äh
War das richtig für Bios?
Ok
Also Bios Settings
Bios Settings dafür, ok
ILO ist Disabled
Ja
Ich weiß, weil ich hab ja auch kein ILO Kit drin
Was haben wir denn so zu bieten?
System Configuration
ILO, was?
ILO Configuration Utility
Wie soll ich denn ein ILO Configuraten
Ohne das ich ein ILO drinne hab?
Man weiß es nicht
Bios Plattform Configuration
Boah, was kann man da alles einstellen?
System Options
Boot Time Optimization
Extended Memory Test Memory
Fast Training
Discovery Mode
Also ganz ehrlich, solange ich nicht weiß, was es ist
Lass ich es einfach bleiben
Bios Serial Console & EMS
Keine Ahnung, lass ich an
Ok, Virtual Serial Port, brauch ich nicht
USB Options
All Ports Enabled
Support USB Boot, ja
Das muss sein
Server Availability
Der ASERI Status
IPMI Watchdog Timer
Wake Online
Server Asset Information
Ne, Diagnostics wollen wir nicht machen
Processor Options
Ja, alle Cores
Memory Options
Virtualisierungs Options
Alles Enabled, sehr gut
Boot Options
UEFI Mode
Jaja
Ich will auch UEFI Mode lassen
Network Options
Boah, du kannst direkt WLAN Config im Bios machen
Und sowas
Nicht schlecht
Storage Options
SATA Controller Options
Was?
Software RAID
Nein, nein, nein, nein, wir wollen garantiert kein Software RAID haben
Fiber Channel Scan Policy
Das Ding hat doch gar keinen Fiber Channel Anschluss
NVM Express
Das Ding hat auch kein NVME
Hä?
Ist das irgend so ein Bios, was die für alle Dell Server verwenden?
Auch welche
Auch welche, die das gar nicht haben
Fiber Channel Over S
Fiber Channel Over Ethernet
Was dann aber keinen Sinn mehr ergibt, dass es Fiber Channel heißt, oder?
Power Regulator
Ja, das ist meine 10G-Karte
Leute, ich glaube, ich muss hier gar nichts großartig einstellen
Das einzige, was ich einstellen will, ist die Bootreihenfolge
Die will ich umstellen
Also machen wir mal schnell
Den USB Stick dran
Den ich wieder rausgezogen hab
Also machen wir mal schnell den USB Stick dran
Ich seh nix
So, USB Stick ist wieder drin
Das stimmt
Fiber Channel ist nur das Protokoll
Aber dreimal darfst du raten, woher Fiber in dem Name kommt
Bestimmt nicht vor einem Kupferkabel
Also du brauchst für das ILO ein extra Kit
Das habe ich auch in einem Review dazu gelesen
Also, wo stelle ich denn die Default System Options?
Ne, wo stellt man denn
device priority der sollte direkt von usb booten eigentlich wenn alles
funktioniert ok ich stöpsel mal ein 10 gigabit kabels dran
ich muss ich muss mal eins aus dem schrank holen ich habe nur eins noch im
schrank und das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen oversized jetzt das sind diese
dinge das hier sind sp plus module guck da 10 gigabit die muss ich jetzt hinten
an switch machen kommen jetzt hier guckt da hinten ist immer das koki essen 10g
switch 10g switch und da kommt es jetzt rein
archi bus ist das bisschen verrutscht
was du eigentlich
und jetzt kommt das in den server rhein 10g ist hier gleich mal gucken ob es
link gibt als schrumpf ich glaube die netzwerkkarte hat keine link anzeige und
laut dem switch ist es auch nicht angegangen bisher warten wir es mal ab
und booten von usb das ist im bios der braucht später braucht der 20 eitel oder
sogar unter 20
das ist jetzt ein bios der bräuche aus irgendwelchen gründen 100 prozent cpu
lasst ok eigentlich werde ich das jetzt so richtig gesehen habe müssen wir nix
einstellen
okay wie komme ich hier raus ok ok andere da sind wir doch erkennt andrade überhaupt
die netzwerkkarte ich hoffe ich komme der porsche ganz diese sendung kommt mit
Ich hoffe doch mal.
Zumindest, dass Putin flutscht.
Ach, die Leute, der USB-Stick geht.
Fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Wir waren uns doch gar nicht sicher, ob der USB-Stick geht.
Aber der USB-Stick geht.
Pock, pock, pock.
Also, man braucht
nicht
kleiner gleich 32G.
Also, meine Netzwerkkarte
synkt immer noch nicht.
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt ist die
Netzwerkkarte abgegangen.
Äh, taugt der GC...
Ach so, du meinst nicht die Netzwerkkarte.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich hab den seit heute
im Einsatz hier.
Der Havaged Demon.
Wird das ein Unraid-Server?
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Sieht so aus.
Guck mal, da hat er auch Melanox
Connect...
Hat er erkannt.
So.
Gebt mir mal die IP.
Warum bootet er bitte schön so lang
bei Starting Havaged...
Hav... Hav...
Vag...
Ged. Alter, was...
Wie spricht man das? Havaged
Entropy Demon.
Havaged.
Hav... Okay, Moment, Sekunde.
Pronounce.
Okay, how to pronounce.
Achtung, Leute.
Havged. Was? Was?
Havged.
Ganz bestimmt.
Havged?
Da sind wir doch.
IP-Address not set.
Hat der Probleme mit der Netzwerkkarte?
Also, Link hat die Netzwerkkarte.
Gehen tut die.
Warum hat das Ding keine...
Wie groß ist das Ding?
128G.
So, wie lockt man sich
Default da ein?
Default Unraid Login.
Ich würde eigentlich erwarten,
dass das sofort...
Funktioniert.
Shell.
Oder muss man einfach nur Enter drücken?
Gut.
Ach so, einfach nur so. Okay.
Null.
Äh, IP-Add.
Wir haben nix.
Aber erkannt hat er es doch, oder?
ETH?
Nee.
Doch.
ETH 4.
ETH 4
müsste das sein.
State down.
Aber der Link ist ab.
Der ist nicht down.
Äh, früher hat...
Was, ETH-Tool?
Haben wir ETH-Tool?
Minus I.
Nee, geht nicht.
Ähm.
Was war das?
IP-Link?
I...
Down.
Steck doch mal das Kabel in einen anderen Port.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das...
Ich habe diesen Port schon verwendet.
Das ist der gleiche Port,
wo wir letztes Mal...
Letztes Mal die andere Kiste dranhängen hatten.
Das liegt...
Das liegt nicht am Switch.
Zumal ja auch Link zwischen Netzwerkkarte und Switch funktioniert.
Ich mache das mal kurz raus,
was er dann sagt.
Jetzt ist das Netzwerkkabel raus.
Oh Gott.
Das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Oh, ich habe die...
Was ist das für ein fucking Tastatur-Layout?
Das dauert drei Stunden, bis das durch ist.
ETH 4 Link down.
Ja, ja.
Ach, ach, komm.
Reingesteckt.
Und jetzt ist der Link oben.
Warum zieht er sich keine IP damit?
Das kann...
Nein.
Die Netzwerkverbindung kann doch nichts mit dem USB-Stick zu tun haben.
Der bootet jetzt.
Und der erkennt auch die Netzwerke.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Down.
BAC klein.
Vielleicht müssen wir sagen...
IP-Conf.
Ich weiß nur, wie es mit IP-Conf geht.
ETH 4 up.
Jetzt...
Nee.
Jetzt ist es ab.
Ja, aber das ist doch scheiße.
Ich will doch, dass es nach dem Reboot automatisch hochkommt, meine Netzwerkkarte.
Unrate 10G-NIC.
Schließ LAN an und geh ins Web, ja, und konfiguriere dort.
Geht das?
Ist das...
sinnvolle Idee?
Ja?
Okay.
Dann schließe ich per Netzwerkkabel an.
Ich muss Netzwerkkabel holen.
Ist klar.
Ich habe es jetzt auch extra an Port 1 gesteckt.
So, wir schauen jetzt erstmal, ob er bei der Gelegenheit überhaupt so bootet, dass er direkt vom USB-Stick bootet.
Ohne, dass ich ihm vorher einen Boot rein vorgesagt habe.
Alter Leute, mir fängt an der Arm weh zu tun, wo ich heute eine neue Antenne bekommen habe.
So, damit initialized.
Guck, ihr seht gleich, wie das runtergeht.
38 Watt.
Und am Ende brauchst du 20.
Super High-Speed-Boot-Vorgang.
Ach so, wir könnten mal gucken, wie es mit BIOS-Update aussieht.
BIOS-Update.
Ich gehe doch noch mal ins BIOS.
Wie macht man hier BIOS-Update?
Gibt es da ein neues?
Microserver-Gen10-Plus-BIOS-Update.
HP RESTful-API?
Wait a minute.
Was macht das Ding?
Warum hat das Ding eine API?
Egal, ich lasse den jetzt einfach mal machen.
Ah, er bootet direkt. Nice.
Das Ding bläst ordentlich beim Start.
Jetzt wird es leiser.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat er sich eine IP geholt hier von dem...
Ah, HEFGET.
HEFGET ist wieder am...
am...
am Bien.
Ach, jetzt geht es schneller.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir auch eine IP.
1 und 2, 1 und 2.
Und 1, 4, 3.
So, get trial key.
Get trial key.
Yes, start trial.
Trial started.
Pock.
Trial ist gelaunched.
Gut, ich habe keinerlei Disks drin.
Ich kann das...
Ich kann das Array gerade gar nicht starten.
Aber man kann auch bestimmt schon in die Settings gehen.
Settings?
Network Settings?
Wahrscheinlich.
Interface Description.
ETH 1, ETH 4.
Hier ist ETH 4.
Hier, das ist die richtige.
Shutdown inactive.
Äh.
Ja?
Ach, Port up.
Musst du ETH 4 in den Bond aufnehmen?
Haben die einen Bonding?
Nee, oder?
Ach, tatsächlich.
Warum haben die denn...
Äh.
But why?
Wa...
Warum?
Warum überhaupt Bonding?
Standardmäßig?
Ich will das als einzige Netzwerkkarte und gut ist...
Äh, so.
Hier, not configured.
Enable Bonding.
Enable Bridging.
Was will ich?
Ich will einfach, dass du darauf dein Admin Interface...
Erreichbar bist.
Okay, ich vermute mal.
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal für was, was, was steht.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Also, ich vermute mal, Bonding ist rein für HA-Geschichten.
Mehrere Interfaces zusammen.
Bridging ist, dass ich meine 4Ms...
Also, dass ich die Netzwerkkarte an die Bridge hänge.
Äh, wo dann auch am Ende die 4Ms und so drankommen können.
Oder?
Ja.
Siehste?
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Enable Bonding.
Brauche ich auch nicht.
Ich will einfach nur, dass du dir eine IP-Adresse ziehst.
Automatic.
Genau.
Apply.
Mehr will ich gar nicht.
Zieh dir eine IP und fertig aus.
Hat er.
Nice.
Okay, das bedeutet auch, wenn ich da jetzt reboote...
Reboot.
Wobei, ich kann, ich kann, ich muss, ich kann das ja auch übers...
Äh...
Hier, selbst, selbst rebooten.
Shares.
Warum ist der Reboot eigentlich unter den, unter den...
Unter der RAID-Config und nicht unter Settings?
Reboot.
Proceed.
So, und jetzt ziehe ich nämlich einfach hinten das Netzwerkkabel raus für die normale Netzwerkkarte.
Und dann sollte er ja beim Booten theoretisch nur mit der 10G-Karte booten.
Hätte ich noch irgendwas speichern müssen, Chat?
Oder war das so okay?
Oder war das so okay, was ich gemacht hab?
Also, guck mal.
Wir haben BIOS-Version 2.5...
2.5.2.
Und hier gibt es...
Hier gibt es 2...
Hä?
Warum blickt man bei diesen Support-Seiten von den Serverherstellern nie durch?
Es ist egal, ob es IBM, Lenovo ist, ob es HP ist, ob es Dell ist, ob es sonst was ist.
Diese Seiten sind immer so gemacht, dass es keine Sau versteht.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist 2.5.6.
So, und wir hatten 2.5.2.
Hier, wir haben das BIOS.
Das heißt, danach kam noch...
Danach kam noch das hier.
Intel-IPU, which provides...
Irgendeine Meltdown-Geschichte haben wir noch.
Und Security-Geschichten.
Scheiß drauf.
Oh.
Wir können auch Power-Top gleich mal installieren.
Und Stromsparzeug.
Unraid.
Save.
Power.
Ah, tatsächlich, da gibt es sogar Power-Top am Start.
Haben die sogar schon mit drauf.
Wir machen jetzt mal Power-Top an.
Falls es schon installiert ist.
Oh.
RIP.
Das macht mich nicht sonderlich zuversichtlich in dieses Produkt, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
SDP-Stage ist ein Garbage.
Vielleicht macht der gleich noch weiter.
Ja.
Link hat er schon mal.
Netzwerk.
Technisch.
Er hat keine IP.
Guckt euch das an.
Ja, das ist sehr hängen geblieben.
Aber er ist immerhin stayed up.
Er hat auch eine IP.
Funktioniert das jetzt doch?
Geht?
Das Ding kann das nur nicht anzeigen.
IP not set?
Nee, Management ist auch hier.
Muss ich die anderen jetzt disablen, erst mal, dass er das checkt?
No.
Oh.
Alter, mein Browser ist gerade gecrashed.
Mein Browser ist gecrashed.
What the fuck?
Oh ja, das sieht gut aus.
Kann man das nicht einfach deaktivieren?
Ich meine, das funktioniert ja.
Es tut ja.
Er hat ja die IP und so.
Das ist ja alles richtig.
Kann man den Scheiß nicht einfach deaktivieren?
Interface null.
Shutdown inactive.
Okay.
Ja.
Kann ich das jetzt nicht auch einfach inactive machen?
Weil ich hab, ich hab ja ein Interface.
Ich hab ja ETH 4.
Was funktioniert?
Enable Bonding.
No.
Preaching.
Ich will das Interface ausschalten.
Please.
Ist das erlaubt?
Wie schalte ich das Interface aus?
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Lager.
gar nicht ich kann es nicht raus machen dass ip assignment nun das geht nicht
der ist der meinung er muss eth 0 konfigurieren oder so was auch immer
das ist ziemlicher pains champ dass ich bin ich der netzwerkkarte aussuchen kann
die ich haben will es ist ziemlich dumm naja ok man eth 0
port ist da kann man die kann man die default kann man die default nicht
ändern android change default network oder
default make a network interface default ja you can change which device eth 0
interface ruhe ok ich habe es geprägt leute interface
schul interface
alter da kommt doch keiner drauf man heck wait heck wait also was ist hier die
sechs hinten ist das okay die sechs hinten wird dann eth 4 apply oh ne ne
schlecht schlecht schlecht ah ne jetzt jetzt das soll das sein
enable bonding yes no no no kein bonding bridging no wozu so eth 4 und eth 4 möchte ich jetzt
eth 4 möchte ich jetzt
fitz abelnes und das ist natürlich doof hab ich mich jetzt habe ich mich ein
fitz abelnes und das ist natürlich doof hab ich mich jetzt hab ich mich ein
selbst ausgesperrt gerade aber er sollte sich doch eigentlich jetzt eine
neue powin tenddie es ist ja auch automatic
neue fenster rolled out
ich glaube jetzt muss ich muten leute ich glaube ich muss rom mach brüttgen
Posten zu ver님이 tilda
dich ja machen nee, brauch ich nicht paar nicht ausprobieren mal ausprobieren
eben ausprobieren we glaubt ihr dich auf mich zu geben
max seht ihr ihrственныйに
mal ausprobieren war ausprobiert wie gut achieving antics들 barclays das haben sie tasted zero now
Da steht noch Bahnhof Nice auf Stream.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Gleich kann Havagate
Demon wieder. Guck, jetzt sind wir
nur schon bei 21 Watt.
Das ist durchaus okay und ich glaube, wenn wir einen
Powertop machen, mit Powertop
sind wir sogar noch ein bisschen
geringer
klein.
Mario Kart Musik
Leute, ich muss mal
richtig dringend
Pipo Pupu machen, aber ich will jetzt erst gucken,
ob die Netzwerkkarte funktioniert.
Was hast du für den Gen 10 Geld da gelassen?
Irgendwie um die 700 Euro.
Du hast nebenbei deinen eigenen Android-Server
neu aufgesetzt. Nice.
Was sind die Specs?
Also ausgeliefert wird das Ding mit 16 GB RAM
und
einem Xeon E
2224. Das ist ein Vierkerner
mit, glaube ich, Boost auf 4,7
Gigahertz. Kannst hier gucken.
HP Microserver
Gen 10 Plus.
Der da ist das.
Die kleinste
Variante hier, die würde ich mir nicht holen.
Die kleinste Variante ist mit einem
Pentium Dings
G5420.
Also da würde ich lieber gleich die Xeon Kiste nehmen.
Also so viel habe ich definitiv nicht bezahlt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe irgendwas um 700.
Euro bezahlt.
Was willst du mit dem Ding machen? Das ist noch nicht so ganz raus.
Ich werde mich erstmal ein bisschen
an Android rantasten. Ich war ja da überhaupt
kein Fan. Guck mal, jetzt hat es klappt.
Klappt mit der Netzwerkkarte. Überhaupt kein
großer Fan von. Ich habe die ganze Zeit einfach
mein, ähm,
meine Ubuntu-Kiste hier
gehabt.
Und Docker Compose
drauf, KVM drauf,
eine VM laufen, keine Ahnung, 8 Container
oder so. Fertig. Guck mal, er hat es gecheckt.
Es hat funktioniert.
Oder auch nicht.
Ah doch. Nice.
Settings, Network
Settings. Er hat es kapiert.
Okay. Sehr schön.
ETH 4, Port
kann down. Vollkommen in Ordnung. Brauchen wir nicht mehr.
So, ETH 0,
Enable Bridging. Lasse ich alles aus.
Enable Bonding lasse ich auch aus.
WLAN Config brauchen wir nicht. Automatic, Automatic.
Alles gut.
Sehr schön.
Gut. Nice.
So, jetzt machen wir mal Power-Top. Okay, also Leute, ihr seht's,
idle sind wir bei 22 Watt
gerade. Was ich
durchaus akzeptabel
finde.
So. Und jetzt gehen wir mal hier rein
und machen mal Power-Top.
Wobei, ich kann doch jetzt auch über SSH drauf.
Jetzt muss ich das nicht über die Konsole machen.
Jetzt kann ich doch auch drauf mit...
Ah, ich habe zu viel Zeug auf.
Hier. SSH.
SSH.
Wahrscheinlich Root.
Oder muss man SSH extra
konfigurieren? Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich muss man SSH extra konfigurieren.
Alles andere wäre ja blöd, wenn man mir mal ein Passwort
vergeben.
Äh, SSH?
Management Access wahrscheinlich.
SSH Port 22.
Ja, mit welchem Passwort?
Mit welchem Passwort?
Unrate SSH
Default Passwort.
Ah, in User Settings
muss man extra User für anlegen, oder wie?
User?
Nee.
Choose Teldat. Ach hier, User.
Gut. Passwort.
Hoho, Leute.
Nicht, dass ihr mein Passwort noch seht.
Wehe, der sagt mir jetzt, das Passwort
ist zu einfach. Wehe.
Nice, da sind wir.
Power-Top.
Ah, ist nicht drauf.
Wie installiert man denn... Moment.
Haben wir denn nicht eben was gesehen?
Unrate Power-Top?
Oder muss man das extra installieren?
Nerd-Power?
Pack-Plugin.
Okay. Das ist... Okay, das heißt, ich brauche jetzt erstmal
User-Add-Ons.
Äh, User-Add-Ons.
Unrate.
Das habe ich schon letztens gelernt, wie das
funktioniert. Da muss man jetzt
irgendeinen GitHub-Link
copy-pasten.
Was auch...
Naja, sagen wir mal,
das wäre schöner gelöst
sein könnte.
Apps. Understand.
Ja, ja. Wer ist das? Nerd-Pack?
Okay.
I understand.
Das da?
Brauche ich dafür einen Rate?
Brauche ich dafür einen Array, dass das funktioniert?
Ist das ein Docker-Container?
Keine Array.
So, ich habe es jetzt in Sales-Haber-Power-Top.
Ne.
Okay.
Ähm.
Wieso nicht einfach ab...
Und Install, weil das, haltet euch fest,
eine Slackware-basierte
Distribution ist.
Du musst in die Unrate-Einstellung.
Und jetzt?
Ah.
Aha.
Power. Top.
Uninstalled.
Okay, das ist schon...
Six hat...
Ach, das ist ein Package-Manager quasi.
Das ist...
Das ist ein Package-Manager.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Oh.
Was?
Der hat Probleme wegen meinem Terminal.
Echo...
Äh, äh...
Export.
Term gleich Xterm.
Okay, wait.
Das ist kein Screen.
Oh, top.
Oh, nein.
Reset.
Ich hab's...
Ich hab's gebraked.
Ich glaube, ich muss das ohne T-Max ausführen.
Weil...
Was auch immer.
Nicht dasρώre Stahl, ist sehr lama..
Nicht dasbing.
W율 ein eigenes Stahl.
Das surprise das unknown.
Okay...
Was ist das knoboths pessoal top?
Ich nehm einen auf...
Ehm!
Noch...
Ich nehm j почти!
voted.
Wir sehen uns zum Start...
Ähhh, gut!
Power?
Top.
Okay, da sind wir.
Da sind wir!
Power top.
Moment.
kaputt gemacht. Das muss aber auch mit TMAX
auch funktionieren.
Erst einmal eine Sache müssen wir machen. SSH
Copy ID.
Gut.
SSH.
Okay, jetzt geht es ohne Passwort.
Powertop.
Das Ding ist...
Das Ding ist ziemlich
broken, das SSH
hier drauf.
Export.
Guck mal, ich kann nicht mal
zurückgehen.
Das ist im TMAX ziemlich
broken, das Ding.
Nein, nein, nein, da will ich Screen in TMAX
öffnen.
Der sagt,
das Terminal Screen,
wo hinter sich TMAX verbirgt in dem Fall,
ist nicht so. Aber ich sage, ohne TMAX
meinetwegen. Powertop.
Probier mal die Webkonsole.
Meinst du, damit geht es besser?
Lass uns einfach mal auf.
Ja, ihr habt recht. Probier mal die Webkonsole.
Oh ja, super.
Oh, Powertop.
Ah, okay.
Ach, jetzt geht es hier auch.
Das ist ja nett.
Wie war das? Tunables?
Bad. Alles bad, Leute.
So bad.
Guck mal, ob das was bringt,
das umzuschalten.
Gut.
Gut, gut, gut, gut, gut, gut, gut.
Kann das mal weggehen da unten, please?
Bad, bad, bad.
Gut.
Gut. Sehr gut.
Jetzt haben wir alles getunet.
Exit.
Oder?
Ist es jetzt weniger geworden?
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Naja, doch.
0,5 Watt weniger.
Ja, Autotune kann man auch machen,
aber das macht ja im Prinzip nur
gleichen Kram.
Okay, Leute.
Das bringt nichts.
Also ich würde mal sagen,
wir haben
ungefähr
21 Watt Idle, was eigentlich okay ist.
Ich meine, das ist nicht so gut wie mein 8 bis 10 Watt Idle Intel Low Power Ding,
aber dafür hat das hier deutlich, deutlich mehr Wumms und ist ein Komplett Package.
Dazu kommt ja noch, dass schon die 10 Gigabit-Karte drin ist, ne?
Also ohne 10 Gigabit-Karte wäre es vielleicht noch besser.
So, wir machen jetzt mal dieses VGA-Ding hier ab.
Brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Ausgespeidert.
Ist es jetzt weniger geworden noch?
Oh, guck mal, ist es weniger geworden.
USB hat Strom gezogen.
Also ich finde es auch durchaus okay.
20 Watt Idle mit einer 10 Gigabit-Karte drin,
kannst du dich doch nicht beschweren.
Es ist doch in Ordnung.
Wir können jetzt mal ein bisschen CPU-Last,
wir können jetzt mal ein bisschen CPU-Last produzieren.
Ist BC drauf?
Ach, gut.
Wie produziere ich denn schön?
Sysbench oder so?
Nee.
Ja, es ist auch kein Stress drauf.
Wie produzieren wir denn jetzt?
Äh, wie produzieren wir denn?
Äääh, wie produzieren wir denn jetzt ordentlich CPU last?
Öäääh, wie produzieren wir denn jetzt ordentlich CPUlast?
Nerd Pack hat das BC?
Ich mein, wir können bestimmt.
Man kann bestimmt auch irgendwie irgendwas lesen aus Death Random oder so.
Aber mit BC ist es am einfachsten.
Find ich.
Bisschen CPU-Last zu erzeugen.
Wir loggen uns mal aus.
So, Nerd Pack?
Das guards think I like that, das ist quasi so eine Art.
Ja. Cool.
Wollte ich jetzt nicht hier einen Button haben?
So, Nerd Pack. Das finde ich gut, das ist quasi so eine Art. Ja. Cool.
Sollte nicht hier ein Button zum installieren sein?
Ah, she baited.
Der ist auch da.
Mein Fenster war nur zu klein.
Dann.
Okay, PC. Sehr schön.
Also Echo, 2 hoch.
Blubb. Nach PC.
Das ist zu viel.
So, jetzt hier.
Ja.
Nice. Okay.
Darf ich T-Max hier drauf starten?
Auch nicht. Hat der jetzt
die große Preisfrage? Hat
T-Max drauf?
Ah, nice.
Da kann ich nämlich auf dem Solver starten.
Da, wo es eigentlich auch hingehört.
Ich meine, warum muss es unbedingt was Slackware-basiertes
sein? Alles andere
bekomme ich hin. Aber
Slackware, nein.
Hardtop ist, glaube ich, standardmäßig drauf.
Okay, lass mal
Hardtop hier mal auf.
Zack. Zack.
Wir haben 4 Kerne.
Zack.
So. Bam.
77 Watt.
Okay, OpenSUSE wäre noch schlimmer.
Das ist wohl richtig.
This is, yes, this is local network.
10 Gigabits local network.
But, äh,
without any drives.
Only 10 Gigabit
Network Adapter
is installed.
So, 78 Watt
volle CPU-Auslastung.
Das geht doch.
Bitte, Hardtop minus D5.
Okay, nice.
WC ist am rödeln.
Chainlaw wieder.
Das ist immer geil, wie sich da alle drüber lustig machen.
By the way, ich spiele in MMO.
Wir haben
4 Deutsche in der Gruppe und 4
äh, ein Native-English-Speaker
und 4 andere Leute, mit denen wir nur Englisch reden.
Das klappt ohne Probleme.
Ja, also 78 Watt
volle Polo, warum nicht?
Ist doch okay.
Volle Pulle.
Ja.
Zack.
Oh.
Nicht ganz volle Pulle.
Halbe Pulle.
Ein Viertel Pulle.
Und jetzt wieder idle.
Ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ähm, was durchaus sein kann, dass man im BIOS noch ein bisschen Stromspar-Kram einschalten kann, ja.
Das müssen wir mal schauen.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Gut, nice.
Gefällt mir.
Sehr schön.
20 Watt idle mit einer 10 Gigabit-Karte drin.
Bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Wir machen das Fenster mal zu.
Weil sonst blicke ich nicht mehr durch.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist er der Meinung, Picture-in-Picture beenden zu müssen.
Okay.
But why?
Äh, root?
Don't save.
Okay, jetzt installieren wir mal die SSDs, würde ich sagen.
Hä?
Mal SSDs rein.
Fangen wir mal, fangen wir mal mit der da an.
Das ist die SanDisk Extreme Pro 2 Terabyte.
Wo habe ich die USB-Kabels hin?
Hier.
So, wichtig.
Wichtig, Leute.
Die SSD, die muss man hier vorne anschließen.
Weil nur die, weil nur diese hier, guckt mal.
Wollen wir mal ein bisschen aus dem Weg fallen.
Nur.
Ah, ich habe mein Headset falsch auf.
Nur diese USBs hier vorne.
Wieder.
Nur die haben 10 Gigabit.
Okay, jetzt geht der Stromverbrauch natürlich ein bisschen hoch.
Jetzt geht der Stromverbrauch natürlich ein bisschen hoch,
weil die SSD dran ist.
Das ist ja klar.
DEMESC.
Oh, ich dachte, der zeigt mir jetzt was an.
Ach, hier, guck mal da.
SDB.
Installed.
Attached Disk.
Ja, das ist die.
Okay, dann machen wir mal ein Cache-Pool, ein Cache-Pool mit einer SSD.
SanDisk Extreme.
Okay.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Hat er die jetzt gemountet?
Oder nicht?
Warum eine USB-SSD?
Weil das 10 Gigabit-USB ist und 10 Gigabit-USB ist schneller.
Als SATA.
Ja, ich packe die SSDs ja auch nicht ins Array.
Hat er die SSD jetzt hier?
MNT?
Äh, nicht MNT.
Doch MNT, oder?
Du brauchst mindestens eine Platte für das Array.
Okay, Leute.
Ich stöpsel jetzt mal diese billige,
diese billige mitgelieferte 1-Terabyte-Platte da rein.
Die da.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Und ich meine,
oh, Moment, ich höre mich selbst.
Was ist hier los?
Warum höre ich mich selbst?
Ich höre mich selbst?
Warum?
ETF?
Ich höre mich an meinem Handy selbst.
Weil ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
Warum höre ich mich auf...
Das hier ist die...
Das ist die Browser-Übertragung, oder?
Wartet mal.
Test.
Test, Test.
Ich höre mich...
Moment, das ist vom Tablet, oder?
Tablet?
Test?
Nein.
Ich höre mich auf dem...
Ich höre mich alles ernstens auf dem...
Dem da.
Höre ich mich...
Wie geht das?
Habe ich das jetzt doppelt an?
Test?
Wie kann ich mich hören?
Hä?
Ich habe das doch gar nicht doppelt an.
So.
Hallo?
Test, Test?
Test?
Ich höre mich doppelt...
Was?
Ist das...
Das ist das Telefon.
Wie kann ich mich auf dem Telefon...
Selbst hören?
Ist das irgendein Mist, was dieses Übertragungsding macht?
Sekunde.
Die NSA-Spyware.
Ja.
Tatsächlich.
So, ich habe mich gemutet.
Jetzt bin ich weg.
Hä?
Das verstehe ich nicht, aber okay.
Na gut.
Dann mache ich mal den Firefox...
Machen wir den Firefox wieder auf.
Äh, das ist...
Das ist irgendein Loopback-Geschiss gewesen.
Keine Ahnung.
Äh.
Okay.
So.
Picture in Picture.
Okay, nice.
So, schauen wir mal, dass es richtig eingestellt ist wieder.
Passt eigentlich.
Ist eigentlich okay.
Na gut.
Dann mache ich mal die Billig-Festplatte rein.
Und dann gucken wir uns das Ganze an.
Hier.
Die Billig-Mitgelieferte.
Ich muss sagen, das sind bei weitem nicht die schönsten Wechsel-Wechsel-Schächte, die ich gesehen habe.
Aber die sind zweckmäßig.
So, jetzt sollte der Stromverbrauch ein bisschen hochgehen, weil wir eine Festplatte angeschlossen haben.
Die fängt sich auch an zu drehen.
Okay.
Äh, Xeon, genau.
Xeon 2-2-2-4-Triple-11.
Triple, was?
Quattro-Quadcore-Kiste.
Okay, Main.
Äh, Disk.
Hatte die jetzt...
Er erkennt die Disk nicht, oder was?
Muss ich rebooten, dass der die Disk erkennt?
Wahrscheinlich, weil es nicht Hotswap-fähig ist, ne?
Ich muss wahrscheinlich rebooten, dass er die Disks erkennt.
Heals Batman.
Na gut, reboot.
Ähm.
Nein.
Die haben kein...
Also, doch.
Aber offiziell nicht supported.
Ja.
Und wahrscheinlich muss man das im BIOS irgendwie einschalten.
Keine Ahnung.
Also, ich habe im Forum gelesen, du kannst meistens Hotplug machen, aber sie übernehmen halt irgendwie keine Garantie, für das es funktioniert.
Das mit Hotplug ist eh so ein Ding.
Du musst ja vorne die Frontblende abziehen.
Was tatsächlich bei dem Gehäuse ziemlich easy geht.
Du musst die Frontblende abziehen zum Auswechseln.
Also, das ist okay.
Muss ich unbedingt Hotplug haben.
Ich fände es auch schöner mit.
Aber, naja.
So.
Schauen wir mal, wie lange der bootet.
Ich würde sagen, bestimmt...
Ach, ich habe gar keine Uhrzeit mehr eingeblendet hier, lul.
Bestimmt eine halbe Minute bootet der.
Halbe Minute bis Minute.
Der macht irgendwelche Self...
Wie viele Festplatten-Slots das hat?
Vier Stück?
Vier Stück vorne?
Hier, guck, da.
Ich zeige es dir.
Hier vorne hast du vier Stück.
Vier Festplatten-Slots.
Und du hast insgesamt zwei 10 Gigabit-USBs, vier 5 Gigabit-USBs.
Also du kriegst da schon einiges an Storage dran.
Leider kein M.2-Slot, das ist doof.
Das stimmt.
Aber ich finde, der 10 Gigabit-USB macht es ein bisschen wett.
Also ist in Ordnung.
Sollte der jetzt nicht gebootet haben?
Boot-Champ?
Ah, da ist er.
Kannst du nicht da einbauen, wo das ILO reinkommt, eine zweite M.2-Karte einbauen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein normaler PCI-Express-Slot ist, da wo das ILO reinkommt.
Aber jetzt gibt es ja eine neue QNAP-Kombikarte mit PCI-Express 3.
Ja, aber die passt nicht ins Gehäuse rein.
Du hast schon was reingesteckt in den ILO-Slot und das ging nicht?
Das hätte mich auch echt gewundert.
Wie denkst du über No-Code, Low-Code?
Oh, hör mal auf.
Wir haben eine Low-Code-Installation daheim.
Das ist, wenn ich weiß, was das ist, das muss irgendwie, ich habe es noch nie in Action gesehen, Low-Code muss sowas sein wie Battlefield 2042 Portal.
So ein grafisches, so ein grafisches...
So ein grafisches Programmier-Tool für Kack-Noobs.
Dass die Personalabteilung sich Kack-Tools für Kack-Jobs zusammenklicken kann.
Du hast die QNAP-Karte reingekommen, echt?
Schenk mir mal einen Link.
QNAP...
Wie heißt das Ding? 10G M2?
Nein, das wird es nicht sein, oder?
Wow, stolzer Preis.
Ist es das?
M2 10G-Konverter?
Trotzdem stolzer Preis.
Oh, gar mit einem Lüfter drauf.
Ein 10G-Kupfer-Port?
Das ist die alte.
Okay, QNAP.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Das finde ich eine interessante Geschichte.
Das ist die neue?
Ne, SATA-Erweiterungskarte.
10.
M2.
Hier.
Aber du kannst doch nicht...
Sind die Dinger ganz normale PCI-Express-Karten und die funktionieren da drin?
Oder ist das irgendwas, wo du das nur in QNAP verwenden kannst?
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee, ja.
Also bräuchte man das da?
Was ist denn der Unterschied da?
Dual?
Ach so, das ist SATA. Das wollen wir.
PCI.
Wisst ihr, was die auch machen könnte?
Sind da unten drunter dann M2-Slots oder wie?
Die könnten doch einfach eine rausbringen mit Onboard.
Aber das ist ein cooles Ding.
Gab es die Karte überhaupt zu kaufen?
Hier anscheinend noch nicht so richtig, oder?
QNAP.
PCI.
Also ich muss sagen, preislich ist es schon durchaus...
Ja.
Ist schon ein bisschen was, ne?
Aber die neue gibt es anscheinend nicht zu kaufen.
Ersatza.de
Noch nie gehört. Weiß nicht, ob ich da was kaufen will.
Aber man muss sagen, preislich ist das schon nicht ohne.
So, okay. Einmal weiter.
Mal schauen.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Hier. Assignedisk. Da hat er es erkannt.
Ein Terabyte. Null.
Cache hat er auch erkannt.
Start.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen jetzt.
Unreal Tournament ist auch noch eine Serie, die irgendwie die Zeit über nicht...
Also die aktuelle Gamingzeit nicht mehr erlebt.
Die wollten ja ein neues Unreal Tournament machen.
Haben dann aber mit Fortnite angefangen und haben sich gedacht...
Fuck you.
Unreal Tournament.
Man muss wissen, der Cache muss zweimal so groß sein wie der Speicher.
Warum sollte er das sein müssen?
Das gibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das war Chibade.
Chibade-Versuch.
Ein massive...
Try.
Warum das 22 Einträge hat?
Ja, das ist ziemlich dumm.
So.
Also, jetzt haben wir hier die Disk am Start.
Jetzt können wir uns da nochmal per SSH drauf verbinden.
TMAG Session starten.
Beste.
So, jetzt gehen wir mal.
Mount. Cache.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Mount Cache. PV ist drauf. Ist PV drauf?
Ja, perfekt.
Also.
Cat.
Dev.
Zero.
Das ist so der einfachste Test, den man machen kann.
Um...
Ist das die Geschwindigkeit?
Und ja, ich weiß, die coolen Leute würden kein Cat verwenden.
Nach blub.image.
So, wie schnell sind wir?
Das ist doch in...
Aha.
Erwischt.
Erwischt!
Wenn der Cache voll ist, wird's langsam.
Erwischt.
DD. Ne, DD ist nicht so schön.
DD ist nicht so schön,
weil DD zeigt den Speed nicht an.
So schön wie PV.
Aha. Aha.
Doch nicht so schnell, wie es am Anfang ausgesehen hat.
Ne, aber der Status Progress...
Eh, warum Zero?
Weil Zero schneller ist als Random.
Sequenziell ist eh egal.
Gerade für den NASCache ist sequenziell doch nicht egal.
egal meiste dürfte sequenziell sein was hat es mit dem cash auf sich die haben
das die haben das recht clever gebastelt das sieht nach außen hin aus wie eine
eine platte aber landet zuerst auf dem cash und wird dann sukzessive
runtergemoved warum sollte es random sein eine datei zu kopieren
dann müsst ihr das was ich hier mache auch random sein der cash der keine
folge gut ich habe keine ahnung was da macht ich hätte jetzt einfach ich werde
davon ausgegangen dass der 1 zu 1 den kram hintereinander wegschreibt ja gut
bei cfs ist das ja was anderes nfs ist ja eh high iq ok also im
durchschnitt so 460 mb da kann ich da bei der geschwindigkeit kann ich auch
eine sata ssd reinhängen
die ist genauso schnell
ungefähr das ist wohl auch das sata ssd limit so in dem dreh das ist okay die
coolen leute würden das glaube ich so machen ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob
das funktioniert doch die coolen leute würden das so machen damit nicht
gekettet da wird input piped und output piped und alles also die coolen leute
machen das so aber das endet an der geschwindigkeit
nicht wirklich was okay also so 400hell Besichern und alles klar
ok las blut evans ag煮 mal gucken wie schnell die platte ist fast foram
thug ge JAMSA find gucken wie schnell dieمaks Oui du Oriana
wir ja ganz schön schnell für sonemagnet festplatte oder das erscheint mir ein
bisschen zu schnell führende machen im festplatte zu sein weil das ist das eine
Für eine 1TB-Platte.
Ist das irgendein Hybrid-Ding
oder so? Ich hätte da jetzt
mit 80 MB gerechnet.
Aber ordentlich.
Das ist okay.
Das ist in Ordnung. Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Okay, und jetzt machen wir die andere
SSD dran.
Wo ist die? Wo habe ich das hin?
Chat, wo ist es?
Da. Jetzt muss ich die SSD
abmachen. Das ist natürlich auch doof.
Oder ich finde
das andere Kabel. Aber ich finde das andere...
Ach doch, hier. Ich habe das andere Kabel gefunden. Alles klar.
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Wir können die parallel
dran machen. Machen wir einen zweiten
Cache-Pool auf.
Zweiter Cache-Pool. Das hier ist jetzt
eine
970 EVO
in so einem M2 zu
USB-Case.
Das Kabel ist halt Müll.
Das ist wahrscheinlich anhand des Kabels
allein schon langsamer.
Auf, geh rein.
Okay, zeigen wir. Gucken wir mal.
Muss ich das, um ein neues
Cache anzulegen, stoppen? Erst das
Array? Wahrscheinlich.
So, da haben wir das hier. Dann brauchen wir noch einen
Cache-Pool.
Cache 2
mit einem Slot. Was?
Two?
Ach gut.
Meinetwegen.
Wieder.
2 Terabyte.
Start.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Wie schnell die ist.
Ja, formatier das alles gut.
Mach.
Okay.
Also wir haben jetzt Cache und Cache 2.
Wie schnell ist Cache 2?
CD, MNT,
Cache 2.
PV.
Aha.
Oh.
Okay, Leute.
Cache 2 gewinnt.
Cache 2.
Ist Cache 2 eine neue CSGO-Map?
Das wär mal was.
Wir sollen uns das patentieren lassen.
Also Leute, Cache 2 gewinnt
aus obvious reasons.
Weil
Cache 2 doppelt so schnell ist
wie Cache 1. Guckt es euch an.
Bei SATA 3
ist das Limit 6 GB.
Ja, aber das kriegst du am Ende nicht.
Du kriegst irgendwas.
Irgendwas mit 500 oder so.
SATA 3 Max Speed.
Okay, 600.
Ist okay.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
In der Praxis bleiben 550.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Genau.
Ich hatte 500 im Kopf.
Also das theoretische Maximum
erreicht sie ja auch bei USB nicht.
USB hat hier 10G.
Aber der macht ja
maximale Bandbreite auf
was weiß ich, Kabel-Level ist irgendwie 10G.
Und...
Ach, Moment, das ist MIP.
Das ist Maybe, Maybe-Bytes
sind das ja. Stimmt.
Hi-Fat-Time.
Das sind ja Maybe-Bytes.
Das ist, das ist...
Supergenau, ja.
Maybe sind 1024, oder?
Und Mega
sind eigentlich
1000 dann.
Oder war es umgedreht?
Oh Gott, dieses...
Das ist so...
Paints-Champ, Alter.
Kann man PV sagen?
Es soll...
PV-Show-Maybe?
PV-Man-Page.
Da ist natürlich kein Man-Page dabei.
Ist natürlich super.
Kann man...
Bytes?
Turn-Total-Bytes-Counter?
Rate-Counter?
Nee.
Okay, dann machen wir das doch mit die Idee.
Okay, wir können es
einfach umrechnen.
Also, 700...
780 Maybe
to MB.
Okay, 817
Megabyte.
Und hier haben wir das da.
Das sind...
Google ist zu blöd.
514.
Na dann.
So ein großer Unterschied macht es in den
Größenordnungen nicht.
Ja gut, trotzdem.
Cash 1
hat verloren. Cash 2 ist der Gewinner.
Eindeutig.
Guckt es euch an.
Oben flutscht das Ganze so mit
700...
Oder was auch immer.
Ah.
Ja. Irgendwas mit 700
noch was.
Und unten irgendwie mit 400 noch was.
Also eindeutig
gewinnt Cash 2.
Das da unten ist wie gesagt...
Da kann ich auch eine SATA-SSD anschließen, Alter.
Allgemein?
Ich könnte eine SATA-SSD anschließen.
Wait a minute.
Wie kriege ich da überhaupt eine SATA-SSD rein?
Wie kriege ich da eine SATA-SSD rein?
Die SATA-SSD sind doch viel, viel, viel...
Die passen doch gar nicht da rein.
Microserver.
Gen. T-Plus.
SATA-SSD.
Das SATA-SSD Enablement Kit.
Ne, das ist das ELO Enablement Kit.
Okay, man muss einen Adapter...
Adapter.
Man kann sich einen Adapter 3D drucken.
SSD.
Thingiverse.
Hier.
Sowas kann man sich ausdrucken für die SSDs.
Big Brain Time.
Nice.
Gut.
Schließen wir nicht an.
Ich bleib bei USB.
Das ist für Gen 8.
Haben die andere Slots bei Gen 8?
Hatte der Gen 8 andere Slots?
Gut.
Nichtsdestotrotz.
Ray...
Äh.
Cash.
Cash Zero gewinnt.
Besser.
Best...
Bester Mann Cash.
Äh.
Cash 2 gewinnt.
Bester Mann Cash 2.
So.
Was ich jetzt noch nicht gecheckt hab ist.
Wie kann ich jetzt das wieder deaktivieren?
Also.
Ich stoppe das.
Ah.
Geh hier mal raus.
Okay.
Ich stoppe das und dann will ich ja die Cash Pools wieder entfernen.
Wie lösche ich den Pool?
Load.
Oh, die war es.
Ah ja.
Jetzt ist er weg.
Oh, die war es.
Device 1 overheated.
Ja, von wegen.
Die Kühlung bringt was.
Wie warm wird's?
Oh.
Leute.
Mäh.
Das ist schon...
Das ist schon ganz ordentlich, was da abgeht.
Und die hier?
Die wird auch...
Oh, die wird auch gut warm.
Warum wird denn der Shit...
Warum wird denn der Shit so heiß?
Das muss...
Das muss ich jetzt mal...
Das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Moment.
So.
Blah.
Start.
Temp.
Overwritten.
Start.
Ja, ja.
Ist gut.
Äh.
Den machen wir wieder ab.
Den brauchen wir nicht.
Auf.
Den brauchen wir erstmal nicht.
Okay.
Ist gestartet.
Nice.
Schön, dass du mir Bescheid sagst, dass meine SSD am Überhitzen ist.
So.
Jetzt haben wir den Krams hier alles.
Ist ja gut.
Cache Pool.
Unassigned Devices.
Ja, das sollte jetzt eigentlich weg sein.
Weil ich es abgesteckt habe.
Wie Unassigned Devices.
Ich hab dich...
Ich hab dich abgesteckt.
Du kannst nicht unassigned sein.
He doesn't know.
He lacks critical information.
Kannst du die SSD aufmachen und so einbauen?
Nö.
Das hat kein M2-Slot, das Ding.
MNT.
Cache.
So.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Wir...
Wir schreiben jetzt die SSD mal voll.
Also, naja, voll.
Wir schreiben ordentlich auf die SSD und überwachen mal die Temperatur von diesem Ding.
Gibt es eine schöne Anzeige, wo man dauerhaft zugucken kann, was die Temperatur macht?
So hier.
Device Information.
Hä?
Wo kann ich ihm denn zugucken, wie warm der...
Ach hier, Temp.
Da.
Aktualisiert sich das auch automatisch?
Oder muss ich...
Oder muss ich permanent...
Refreshen?
Hat er vielleicht Sensors laufen?
Sens...
Sensors!
Nice!
Und ist da das Sensor drin, was ich haben will?
PCI-Adapter?
Seht ihr irgendwo die Platte?
Ne, ne?
Die Platte steht da nicht drin.
Das muss man irgendwie anders...
Irgendwie...
Ist das Smart?
Smart-Abfrage?
Oh, das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
61 Temp.
Ah, Smart...
Siehste, der Chat...
Man muss sagen, der Chat bei mir, der ist wirklich...
Absolut Sixhead.
Massifier-Cue, alle hier.
Smart-X.
Dev...
Ich mach das jetzt einfach.
Vielleicht auch X-Delete oder sowas.
Äh...
Was war's?
Dev-USB?
Ne, äh...
Dev-Disk?
Disk...
By Label, meinetwegen.
Unrate.
Nein.
Dev-By-ID?
Ne, Dev-By...
By Path?
Bei...
By UID?
Ja, na gut.
Dann doch By-ID.
Sandisk Gen 1.
Ne.
Das da.
Part...
Part 1.
Ne, nicht Part 1.
Einfach nur so, ne?
Temperature 91 Grad.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Schön heiß.
Angeblich ist es...
Angeblich ist es nur...
Angeblich sagt er mir, es ist nur 71...
61 Grad.
Wem soll ich da glauben jetzt?
Dem da?
Dem da oder dem da?
Warum nicht Unrate?
Ach so, weil mich der Chat...
Weil mich der Chat drauf gebracht hat.
Passt mal auf.
Mal was checken.
Watch.
Ach so.
Das erzeugt so viel Bullshit-Ausgabe.
Ja.
Machen wir ein neues Tab auf.
Ah.
Watch.
Stimmt, wir können tatsächlich einfach creppen.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Wir creppen nicht.
Wir sind noch schlauer.
Wir machen Tail-N 5.
Tail-N 6.
Ah ja.
Sehr gut.
Okay, ich puste mal.
Mal gucken.
Und jetzt...
Moment.
Was ist es?
Watch minus N 0 1?
Okay.
Wird's kühler?
Hat das was gebracht, dass ich Pust-Champ gemacht hab?
Nö.
Boah, das ist richtig heiß, Leute.
Wird nur wärmer.
Ja, das juckt den überhaupt nicht.
Also, das passive Ding klingt nicht...
Erstmal, ich will...
Ich soll mir vom Bauer...
Der Bauer sollte mir mal ein bisschen seine Tonne flüchten.
Dann muss ich Stickstoff ein bisschen zur Verfügung stellen, hier.
54 Watt.
Volle Pulle, SSD schreiben.
Nice.
No errors.
Guck mal, no errors.
Keine Errors.
Aber der ist konstant.
Also, der brennt schon mal nicht durch.
Sieht man hier die Temperatur irgendwie?
Gibt's eine gescheite Übersicht, was Hardware-Temperatur und so angeht?
Oder gibt's da nur...
Diese Sachen?
Diese Sachen.
Wenn man hier...
Wenn man hier auf Main geht.
By the way, warum der 61 Grad angeblich hat, verstehe ich nicht.
Lese ich das...
Lese ich das Falsche aus, vielleicht?
Lese ich vielleicht das Falsche aus?
Ja, ich mein, vielleicht...
Na gut, das ist die Partition.
Die Partition kann ich ja nix auslesen.
Nein, das Elo...
Ich hab kein Elo-Kit drinne.
Also, anscheinend hängt er...
Kann das sein, dass er drosselt ab 100 Grad?
Dass er den Speed drosselt, wenn er über 100 Grad geht?
Boah, das ist heiß.
Alter, Leute.
Boah.
Das ist nicht ohne.
System-Temperature-Plugin.
Mach aus.
Nein, ich lass das jetzt laufen.
System-Temperature-Plugin haben.
Warum braucht man ein Plugin für?
Apps.
Hast du ein Lü...
Oh.
Er geht aber noch.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Er ist nicht tot.
Er geht noch.
Ich bin noch drauf.
Warum geht das Web-Interface nicht mehr?
Nein, der funktioniert noch.
Er ist doch noch da.
Ich bin noch bei SSH drauf.
Ich hab den Stick nicht beschrieben.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum der nicht läuft.
Engine X abgekackt.
Aber wegen was sollte der den Engine X ab...
Oh.
Kann das sein, dass der Server sich gerade ausschaltet?
Wegen Überhitzung oder so?
Also, der Server wird sich nicht ausschalten.
Aber...
Sag mal, der Cache schaltet sich aus.
Ähm...
Hat das Ding...
Hat...
Hat Unraid irgendeine Protection drin?
Dass der sich rebootet?
Wenn es...
Wenn die Platte Gefahr nimmt, äh...
Damage zu bekommen?
Kann das sein?
Dass der sich gerade rebootet?
Der hat sich ausgeschaltet!
Der hat sich runtergefahren, Leute!
Lull!
Der hat sich runtergefahren.
Das muss irgende...
Das muss garantiert...
Garantiert irgendeine andere schutzvorrichtung sein dass der sich bei 100 grad runter runter fährt
aber wieder an
Sechs werte stand by tja
Ist das überhaupt eu-konform nicht dass die mir mein server jetzt abnehmen fbi open up
Ihr server verbraucht mehr als ein watt eidel
Na die ssds drosseln das wird es nicht sein
Und das muss irgendeine erkennung vom betriebssystem sein dass es runter fährt weil der server wird sich bestimmt nicht
ordnungsgemäß runterfahren nur weil die ssd überhitzt das muss irgendetwas muss das arbeit muss das erkannt haben
und sie gesagt habe ich schalte mich aus
dass ilo macht dass ich habe kein elo drin außerdem hat sich der rechner so heiß geworden sondern die ssd
also das kann ich sein
das stimmt ich habe kein extra adapter
deswegen werden solche ssds auch mit kühlkörpern versiehen ja guck mal da hier ist doch massive kühlkörper siehst du denn nicht
Poggers
ein poggers cooler hier
und auch was da was dafür was dafür rippen drauf sind
Kein luftstrom das ist richtig wo soll der luftstrom auch herkommen
Ich meine vielleicht kann ich das da rein reinhängen
das ist ein 0815 billig billig amazon enclosure
Oh wo sind wir
Warum ist er noch nicht wieder da
Muss man vielleicht irgendwie bestätigen nachdem er sich ausgeschaltet hat
Jeder bootet bestimmt noch der ist bestimmt lahm im booten booten die jetzt von der ssd
Nee das sollte optik da ist er doch der sollte optical drive booten und dann usb da ist er wieder
da ist er wieder guck mal da
der tower
Pass auf jetzt jetzt haut er mich gleich mit irgendeiner warnung voll
Keine warnung bin ich aber enttäuscht
so grafane am laufen ein
also ja aber nicht nicht dafür
sehr spannend
Also wir wissen schon mal dauerhafte
Wo kann man das einstellen das automatische runterfahren
an rate to hot
shut down
Macht das jetzt ist die frage kam das vom android oder kam das vom server
Hat der server das erkannt oder hat android das erkannt
Hat android irgendwie die smart geschichte überwacht hat gesagt ich fahre mich jetzt runter
Oder war das das management ding an toastie
Shut down option ist die version of the parity check tuning plugin
Dann dann ist das kein das ist stimmt wir können
war lockt
Haben wir dazu bieten
messages
Ja gut das ist das was zum teufel haben wir dafür eine zeitzone eingestellt
Pst
Was zum
Kokona time
free freedom oder zulu loganda time ja
Keine ahnung was das ist so wende mal wo kurs stellt man date time
Wir sind nicht utc minus 8 wir sind
utc plus 1 sind wir
Ja jetzt schon viel besser
Okay die zeit
Ja also kann das sein dass ich kein lockt habe von vor dem reboot oder sowas
das wäre ziemlich
doof
In der tat ziemlich dumm ich habe keinen lockt
vor dem reboot
Das kannst du einstellen wenn du auf main gehst und dann auf den datenträgern namen okay
Erst starten oder oder wo wo stellt man das ein
Man auf cash kann es ja so nicht sein oder hier meinst du hier
Das ist ja das ist ja der pool
Nee sowas gibt es nicht indem das ist kein
log das gibt es nur vom laufenden kritiker temperature stress 55 alert notification
dass das dann war das wirklich was vom vom ilo dass er das ausgeschaltet hat tatsächlich gehe
ich gehe ich von aus obama ssd evo 970 max temperature was darf die denn was ist die
maximale temperatur von dem ding was da was darf die denn laut samsung 90 grad stimmt stimmt wir
können tatsächlich wir können gucken smart ctl minus ich stimmt ja ja der disk bei id
und
das ding ja na gut das ist kritiker 85 85 wir sind wir waren bei 100 das ist vielleicht dann
doch ein bisschen viel ja aber das ist war richtig freudig leute soll ich euch das mal sagen das kann
ich nicht verwenden stellt euch mal vor ich kopiere auf mein nass was rüber und das ding
schallt sich einfach aus
was soll ich denn damit also so geht es ja nicht aktive kühlung da gibt es so kleine kühlkörper naja
ich habe ja eigentlich guck mal du siehst das ja das ist ja eigentlich so ein gehäuse was kühlen
soll von der idee her und es ist auch eigentlich egal wie rum ich das rein setzte hat denn das
die ssd richtig kontakt mit dem gehäuse wahrscheinlich nicht es gab keine wärme
leitpads da drin in diesem package oder gab es da wärme leitpads gab es da wärme leitpads
da gab es keine wärme leitpads ich gebe euch recht es wäre ein sinnvolles feature wenn es
wärme leitpads
also
, da sind keine wärme leitpads dabei das ist natürlich ziemlich dumm das fällt mir jetzt so
das ist eigentlich total bescheuert da müssten ja wärme leitpads dabei sein also müssten sind nicht
aber müssten weil ansonsten ist es ja viel viel zu heiß machen was anderes ich schraube das mal auf
ich schraube das mal auf und wir machen das mal raus
man hat mir nichts drauf auf dem cash
was ist mit den kabeln Trung
das kabel ist heute final
salz was ist das für ein usb kabel
schrott china kinesen karte
sonst etwas daran dass man besseren eindruck
unter đâu
angeschmolzen.
Ne, das Kabel ist nicht warm.
Das Kabel ist nicht warm.
Wir machen mal kurz auf und wir lassen es
einfach mal offen. Wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal
offen liegen. Mein Scheiß drauf, dann wird es
wahrscheinlich kühler bleiben, wenn es offen liegt.
Und eventuell, ich habe nämlich eine Idee,
vielleicht kriegen wir es nämlich so hin,
dass wir das sogar hier irgendwie
reinhängen können, dass es so ein bisschen
so ein bisschen Luft
Flow irgendwie abbekommt.
Weil ansonsten stecke ich da einfach
eine SATA-SSD rein und gut ist,
die bleibt kühler.
Ne, das hat null Wärmepads.
Das ist totaler Crap.
Wow.
Da habe ich überhaupt nicht dran gedacht,
dass es Müll ist,
also dass dieses Gehäuse Müll sein muss,
wenn da keine Wärmeleitpads dabei
sind. Weil wozu
hat man ein Alu oder wozu hat man
ein Gehäuse, das
super irgendwie
ableitet, aber das innen
drinnen, guckt euch das mal an, das innen
drinnen hat ja überhaupt kein
überhaupt kein Kontakt so richtig
zum Gehäuse.
Das ist ja einfach
nur dumm.
So, ich schließe es jetzt an
und dann
lassen wir es einfach mal offen.
Gucken, was es dann sagt.
Ja, ich lasse es
jetzt einfach mal hier liegen.
Schauen wir mal. Es leuchtet
auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Heiß-blau.
Das ist blaues Licht, Leute.
Du schmierst das in Wärmeleitpaste
ein.
Beste, beste, beste Idee
des Tages.
So, ist das jetzt wieder online, wenn ich es
angesteckt habe oder hat er das jetzt nicht kapiert?
Ah, ich habe es noch gar nicht
gestartet. Gut, Start.
Cache.
So, jetzt haben wir den wieder drinnen.
Also,
MNT, Cache,
Cacher.
Cache.
Irgendjemand hat gesagt, ich soll mal einen Cacher holen.
Ist Cacher nicht so ein Hochdruckreiniger?
Also, nach
370 Gigabyte hat es sich
ausgeschaltet.
Ist ein bisschen viel.
So, Dev...
Nein, nein, nein. Nicht nach Dev Zero.
Schwachsinn. Blub Image
Input Dev Zero.
Ich bin dumm.
Guck mal, das ist doch Schwachsinn. Ich habe hier...
Muss das T-Max hier drauf starten noch.
So, MNT, Cache.
Bam.
Und jetzt...
Smart, Smart,
CTL, Minus X,
Dev,
Disk,
Buy ID,
Gib ihm.
Alter.
Warum?
Das geht mega schnell hoch.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Moment.
Das darf nicht weiter hoch gehen.
Der ist fertig.
Ach ne, der schreibt noch.
Der schreibt, glaube ich, gerade noch ein bisschen die Sachen weg.
So, jetzt sollte er runter gehen.
Hm.
Oh, oh.
Alter, das ist aber krass warm.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Wait a minute.
Warum geht das immer weiter hoch?
Da schreibt doch gar nichts mehr.
Wie doll steigt der Stromverbrauch?
Siehst du?
Hier oben, guck mal.
Komm, mal gucken.
Stimmt, wahrscheinlich ist das...
Jetzt geht er wieder ein bisschen runter.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Temperature Sensor One und Temperature Sensor Two?
Samsung Evo Temperature Sensor One Sensor.
Oh, guck mal, der hat auch heftige Temperaturen.
Einer für den Speicher, einer für den Gumpel.
Das könnte tatsächlich sein.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Hast du nicht einen USB-Lüfter?
Doch, habe ich.
Aber das bringt ja nichts.
Ich will das ja wieder zumachen, das Gehäuse.
Cool, cool.
Äh, flutscht.
Mal gucken, wie warm der wird.
Was war es?
Tail minus 5, ne?
Ne, minus 8 oder so.
Ja.
Ja, das geht schon ganz schön rauf.
Ja, ja, Luftstromhilflasern.
Luftstromhilflasern.
Aber ich kann ja schlechten USB-Lüfter ins Gehäuse bauen.
Vielleicht mache ich wirklich einfach eine SATA-SSD rein und gut ist.
Der ist schon relativ toasty, könnte man so ausdrücken, wie die es eben im Forum gesagt haben.
Leute, ich muss übrigens demnächst futtern.
Wir basteln an einem anderen Tag weiter.
Vielleicht streame ich nachher noch ein bisschen Dark für die Oldschool-MMO-Leute unter uns.
16 Watt für Schreiben.
Zeig mal.
Boah.
Ja, kein Wunder, dass das warm wird.
Kein Wunder, dass das warm wird.
Wenn der, wenn der einfach...
Na gut, ne, das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das sind ja auch, das sind ja auch CPU-Last.
Das sind ja auch, das ist ja auch die CPU-Last.
Das ist ja nicht nur die SSD, die das irgendwie braucht.
Das würde gar nicht über USB, gar nicht gescheit funktionieren.
Wie ist deine Meinung zu Lost Ark?
Äh, ich finde das Spiel echt nicht schnübel, was ich mir angeguckt habe bisher.
Ich bin, ich bin wirklich am überlegen, es auszuprümmeln.
Das Problem ist so, ich habe überhaupt keine Zeit, irgendwie noch nebenbei noch ein zweites MMO zu spielen.
Ich habe jetzt schon seit 8 Tagen kein Video mehr gemacht.
Aber ich habe gestern eins aufgenommen.
Wie 100 hast du gesehen vor circa einer halben Stunde?
Was? Warum macht der überhaupt noch was?
Jetzt ist er fertig. Jetzt sollte er weiter runter gehen.
Alter, Leute, ich sage euch, das ist...
Nicht ohne da drauf zu greifen.
105 ist Backlimit.
RIP.
F.
Ich schreibe, oder?
Wenn ich jetzt, würde ich jetzt mal, ah jetzt geht der runter.
Cache Disc returned to normal temperature.
Sag mal, lies der irgendwas anderes aus als ich?
Was gibt ein Sensor's nochmal aus?
Sensor's.
Ein Sensor's gibt mir nichts von der Disc aus.
Hier ist nix.
Was liest, was genau liest UnRaid denn...
da aus das hier kann es ja offensichtlich nicht sein er liest ja aus 44 grad er sagt es ist 44
grad aber hier ist das 71 also was liest er aus vielleicht ist er nur alle zehn minuten aus
vielleicht aber 44 grad war das ding hier noch nie das war noch nie 44 grad ja keine ahnung was der
ausliest wo steht da 1727 ja da oben das ist war vor fünf minuten aber guck mal angeblich sind es
gerade ein paar hier sind 867 grad und er meint 44 schau mal mit nvme smart lockt was mit was
oder mit smart lock also smart ctl
habe ich nicht gibt es nicht ich weiß nicht was der ausliest na gut es ist ja auch geht das auch
bei nvme über usb weil die sind ja per usb dran wir können mal gucken wo konnte man das in den
settings umstellen settings nein nein nein es gibt kein ab das ist lackware aller slack wäre
guck mal hier nvme best slacker ich weiß auch nicht warum es umgestellt ist aber routine ist
cool ich meine ich bin ein bisschen langweilig und ich weiß nicht was da drinnen drin ist aber ich
unbedingt Slackware sein musste bei denen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das über USB
funktioniert.
Aha.
Was mache ich damit jetzt?
NVMe?
NVMe? List?
Ah, ne, geht nicht. Wahrscheinlich, weil es
per USB dran ist, wird das nicht funktionieren.
Ne, ne, das, das, das, ne, das wird nicht, das
klappt nicht. Das, das
klappt nicht. Ne, ne. Wenn, wenn List
schon nichts anzeigt,
das kann sein, dass sie das ursprünglich mal mit Slackware
gestartet haben. Also
irgendeiner hat auch gesagt,
Plugins Temperature anzeigen.
Temperature.
Temp?
System Temp. Ne, das,
das will ich nicht.
Unraid Disk Temperature
App.
Dynamic System Temperature.
Ja, aber da ist noch keine Festplatte
dabei, oder? Das ist
Pearl.
Wonka S.
Egal,
zitiere ich das jetzt mal.
Und wo gucke ich mir das jetzt an?
Äh, Settings?
Temp?
Nein.
Mainboard, das ist was anderes, brauchen wir nicht.
Das ist Müll.
Ja, also mich würde tatsächlich mal brennend
interessieren, was das Ding,
woher das Ding, das, die,
die Werte bekommt.
Modcheck? Modcheck? Wo sind die Mods?
Ich lese öfters
den Chat.
Aber ich kann natürlich nicht alles lesen.
Was ist, was ist hier?
Ach so, ich sehe es ja.
Oh.
Ähm.
Disk Statistics. Ach ne, das ist das hier.
Sag mal, kann das sein,
dass sich die 44 Grad nie ändern?
Dass der einfach nicht in der Lage ist,
das richtig auszulesen?
Ne, ich will erstmal wissen, warum meine
S das, ne, guck mal, der kann die,
ich glaube, der kann die Temperatur ja einfach
richtig auslesen.
Ich glaube mal eher,
das, was hier unten stimmt und nicht das,
was hier oben steht.
Du hattest doch mal gesagt, du magst Ruby.
Ja, das stimmt.
Würdest du mal einen Ruby-Stream machen?
Boah, Ruby ist halt mittlerweile so ziemlich
unnützig, unnütz geworden, seitdem Rails
keiner mehr verwendet, wobei ich persönlich
halt auch viel Shell-Gedöns in Ruby, also
Kommandozeilen-Zeug in Ruby gemacht habe.
Gar nicht so sehr Rails, aber Ruby ist in
der Bedeutungslosigkeit versunken.
Ist es hardcoded 44 Grad?
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich viel, das ist so wie
Random Badebian früher.
Return 5.
Random.
Ja, gut, Leute, ich gehe jetzt, ich gehe
jetzt gleich was fordern.
Ich lasse es, ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal
laufen, bis der Server wieder ausgeht.
Einfach mal um zu gucken, ob das besser ist,
wenn es, wenn es offen liegt oder nicht.
Aber ich meine, das wird schon so warm.
Wenn ich hier die Hand nur drüber halte,
merke ich schon, dass es ordentlich, ordentlich
abgeht.
Guck nochmal bei Apps.
Was haben wir noch?
Temp.
HDD Temp.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Nee, nee, brauchen wir, brauchen wir noch nicht.
Also ich, ich traue dem Zeugs hier schon,
dass das erscheint mir am sinnigsten zu sein,
was, was hier steht.
Ich glaube, Unraid selber ist nicht in der Lage,
gerade 44 Grad.
Jaja, ist klar, ist klar.
Essen auf NVMe SSD braten.
Das.
Wär's, ja, das ist die HDD-Temperatur.
Ja gut, aber die HDD-Temperatur ist laut Smart auf 105 Grad.
Was?
CPU?
Das ist doch nicht die CPU-Temperatur.
Das ist die, das ist die Platten-Temperatur und das ist auch die Platten-Temperatur.
Zumindest sagt er das.
Was aber ja nicht stimmt.
Jetzt drosselt die SSD.
Schaut so aus, ja.
Ja, guck mal, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's auch langsamer, seht ihr?
Jetzt geht's runter, jetzt geht's runter auf, aufs, jaja, jetzt drosselt das.
Da seht ihr mal, dieses komische Gehäuse hat im Endeffekt die Sache schlimmer gemacht als so.
Also diese, dieses dumme Gehäuse hier hat es quasi heißer gemacht, als es notwendig ist.
Ist übrigens immer noch warm, das Gehäuse.
Crap, crap.
Was gibt's denn schöne, okay, bei der Gelegenheit.
Wir gucken mal kurz bei Amazon.
NVMe USB.
Was gibt's da für schöne Gehäuse?
Das ist alles der gleiche Billig-China-Crap, den ich auch hab.
Das ist der Billig-China-Crap, den ich auch hab.
Gibt es, gibt's da irgendwas Besseres?
Such was von ICY, das ist ein ICY-Ding, was ich hab.
Guck mal, das hab ich.
Das ist das gleiche Billig-China-Ding wie alles andere, was du hier siehst.
Und das bringt's nicht wirklich.
Das von Asus.
Du meinst Asus?
Wow.
RGB.
Nice.
Das Asus ROG Strix.
Arion M2 NVMe SSD.
Hauptsache RGB.
Ähm.
Und warum ist das jetzt besser?
Ah, weil es Thermal Pads hat.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ah.
Äh.
Ich komm gleich runter.
Leute, es gibt Hapa Hapa.
Ich muss off.
Pepo Fett.
Läuft die Sandes auch so ultra heiß?
Nee.
Aber die ist auch langsamer.
Okay, also.
Wir wissen schon mal.
Es ist eine dumme Idee.
Das Ding in das Gehäuse zu stecken.
So passt das.
So passt das halbwegs.
So, und wenn ich jetzt noch irgendwie.
Mit einem bisschen längeren Kabel vielleicht.
Also ich überleg grad.
Wenn ich das da hinten irgendwie reingesteckt bekommen würde.
So hinter die, hinter die Festplattenkühlung oder so.
Hat das Ding überhaupt eine Festplattenkühlung?
Nee, das hat hier.
Das hat nur in der CPU einen Kühler, das ganze Ding.
Also müsste ich, müsste ich theoretisch zu machen.
Ich müsste es zu machen und dann irgendwo hier.
Hier rein, hier reinlegen oder so.
Gucken, ob ich das, ob ich das irgendwie hinkriege.
Zumindest, wenn das Ding offen ist.
Dann drosselt sich die SSD und es passt alles.
Aber es ist schon.
Es ist schon krass heiß, das Ding.
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal laufen, während ich unten essen bin und schreibe die SSD voll und mal gucken, ob er sich ausschaltet.
Wir sehen uns.
Vielleicht stream ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube erst morgen früh.
Gucken wir mal.
Bis dann, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
CU.